hey everybody welcome to the podcast so
some of you
long time viewers are likely at this
point familiar with my
obsession with sleep well a huge reason
for this
is due in no small part to today's guest
an amazing human and one of the world's
leading researchers in the field of
sleep science
his name is matthew walker he's a former
professor of psychiatry at harvard
medical school
and a current professor of neuroscience
and psychology at uc berkeley where he
also serves as founder and director
of the center for human sleep science
his book why we sleep is an
international smash best seller
it's an extraordinary evidence-based
primer on all facets of sleep
it's a read that personally has
profoundly impacted me
and i say this without any hyperbole a
must
for anyone and everyone looking to live
and feel
better matthew's somebody i've wanted to
have on the show for ages and
ages i'm over the moon that he's here
today
and this conversation might be long it's
three hours long but
fear not it is utterly utterly
fascinating
essential listening profound
life-altering and
everything i hoped it would be so please
hit that subscribe button if you haven't
already
thank you and strap in this is me
and dr matthew walker
[Music]
well matthew so delighted to have you
here
people who listen or watch this show
know well
my uh level of obsession with sleep
i'm going to try to uh refrain from
making it uh
basically an indulgent referendum on my
sleeping picture
i know that's great i'm sure i will
diverge into that at some point because
i think it's instructive but
i've been looking forward to this for a
very long time a huge fan of the work
that that you do
and it's just a pleasure and an honor to
have you here today well it's a
privilege and a delight to be sitting
across from you and
i'm a long time listener as well so cool
thank you
that you do yeah absolutely um
one of the i want to kick off with this
one of the super
interesting hypotheses in the book is
this that you
that you that you purport
is this idea that sleep evolved before
the brain hence before
wakefulness so the lens through which we
think about sleep is sort of in reverse
right the question
shouldn't be why do we sleep the
question is really why why are we
awake right and whether or not that's
true i think it's super
interesting and instructive to kind of
shift that lens
and when you think about it from that
perspective everything seems a little
bit different
yeah it isn't and i have no good sound
evidence for that
theory right now but i think from an
evolutionary perspective the first thing
which
perplexes me is the idiocy of sleep
you know when you think of sleep from an
evolutionary perspective
firstly you're not finding a mate you're
not reproducing
you're not caring for you're young
you're not
foraging for food and worst of all
you're vulnerable to predation
so not only that you're an insane person
right you go through this whole thing
like
if you were awake and you were
experiencing the states that you
experienced when you were asleep you
would be
institutionalized that's right yeah then
that's what we call dream sleep which
just seems to be
normal but you know on any one of those
grounds
sleep should have been strongly selected
against
in the course of evolution but the fact
that sleep
has fought its way through along
every step of the evolutionary pathway
in fact if we look back we can even find
sleep-like states in earthworms
which are ancient from an evolutionary
perspective so in other words
sleep evolved with life itself on this
planet
and then despite all of those trappings
it fought its way through heroically
every step along the evolutionary
pathway
in other words if sleep doesn't serve
some absolutely vital set of functions
it's probably the biggest mistake that
the evolutionary processes
has ever made right and we've now
realized that it didn't make a
spectacular
blender but that premise that
sleep evolved is usually founded on the
idea that we were
awake and then we evolved to sleep
and one thought that crossed my mind and
i was perhaps stupid enough to write it
in the book
i wonder if it's the other way around
why did we assume
that we evolved sleep
why don't we assume that sleep is the de
facto state
of all birth life on planet earth
and it's from sleep that wakefulness
emerged and evolved now shy of a
time capsule or some serious smelling
salts i'm probably not going to be able
to go back and
yeah figure that out but i think it's an
interesting sort of way to
sort of well the the the evolutionary
advantage of wakefulness is self-evident
right we need to procreate we need to
feed ourselves
but less obvious is the evolutionary
advantage of sleep it just strikes us
as being something that gets in the way
as opposed to
crucial for all the functions that you
kind of go through siri adam in the book
and i think that's perhaps one of the
reasons that people
are so misunderstanding of sleep
and so understandably neglecting
of sleep because most people if you
didn't understand what sleep is you
would think well
my body gets some rest and my mind is
dormant
and nothing could be further from the
truth
there is an immense cascade of health
benefits this constellation of night
time
gifts that sleep will provide to your
body
and every operation of the mind that we
know is overhauled
some spectacular things in fact during
certain stages of sleep your brain is up
to 30 percent
more active than when you're awake
and so it's so understanding that we
would think well you know if i didn't
know anything about sleep
surely i can just shave off an hour here
or two and
it just doesn't work like that you know
i
one hour we can think of this incredible
global experiment
that's performed on um well over
um 60 billion people across 70 sorry
well over um 2 billion people across 70
countries twice a year
it's called daylight savings time and
what we've discovered
is that in the spring when we lose just
one hour of sleep
there is a 24 increase
in heart attacks the following day so
crazy yet in the
reverse yeah exactly you sort of see i
think it's a 21
reduction in heart attack so that's how
fragile by the way yet if everybody was
sleeping eight hours a night
it would it would be irrelevant right so
it's less about daylight savings time
than it is about our social constructs
around when we need to get up and go to
work or go to school
that's right yeah i think you know
society
um has firstly stigmatized
sleep with this label of laziness that
you know if you're getting sufficient
sleep you're
maybe slothful um and sometimes when i'm
at speaking events people will come up
and they'll usually wait right until the
end of the line of questions
and they'll whisper sort of to me look
i'm one of those people who needs
gosh probably about eight hours of sleep
and you know as if
this this the worst secret the worst the
most shameful thing that you could ever
suggest
so i think that's the first issue but
then were working
longer hours and pre-pandemic
you know commuting times had also
increased
and when you think about that so we're
leaving the house
earlier we're arriving home later you
know nobody
wants to short change on time with
family or
netflix or whatever it is and so the one
thing that gets
squeezed like vice grips in the middle
of the night is this thing called a full
night of sleep
mm-hmm yeah you're almost uh some kind
of
punk rock revolutionary if you protect
your sleep time right it is the one
thing that's negotiable
or dispensable yeah when you're looking
at how you allocate your time
that's right it seems to be and the of
course the the reality is that sleep
alas is not an optional lifestyle luxury
it's a non-negotiable biological
necessity
it is your life support system well we
all know the
the people who say i need i only need
four hours or i only i'm fine on five
hours and i think you have
i've heard you say something along the
lines of zero percent of people
need less than x number of hours like
that's all a story that people tell
themselves but it's simply
not the case that's right yeah so i
think
if you look at the weight of the
evidence the number of people who can
survive
on five hours of sleep or less without
showing any impairment
rounded to a whole number and expressed
as a percent of the population is zero
um and it's
to me you would ask the question well
why do people think that they're doing
okay and what we've discovered
is that your subjective sense
of how well you're doing when you are
insufficiently slapped
is a miserable predictor of objectively
how you're doing
when you're insufficiently slept and so
you know it's a little bit like
a drunk driver at a bar you know they've
had six or seven shots
and they pick up their car keys and they
say look i'm fine to drive home
and your response is i know that you
think you're fine to drive home but
trust me objectively
you're in no state and it's the same way
with a lack of sleep so that's one of
the
sort of the frightening aspects um of
insufficient sleep that you think you're
doing just fine and gradually over time
that deficient form of you
becomes the new norm and most people
don't go from sleeping
eight hours down to five hours it's this
sort of gradual chipping away at their
sleep time
and they don't realize the version of
themselves
and a great example of this clinically
is in sleep disorders
such as sleep apnea and these patients
will say to you look
doc i think i'm fine i think i'm doing
pretty well
and then you treat the sleep apnea so
they start sleeping better they're not
snoring they're not gasping for breath
and within a few weeks they cannot
believe the transformed state of
themselves
i had one patient who said um you know
it was as though
with the sleep apnea device i'd come
along and i'd wiped a frosted window
clear
and finally i could see again wow and
that's the type of
mental benefit that you get and of
course physiologically it's amazing
yeah yeah yeah i mean i just know you
know when you're younger
sleep comes easy as you start to age it
becomes a little bit more fragile and
elusive
and i found myself having to really be
much more intentional about it
and the difference between having a good
night's sleep where i get my eight hours
and you know i know that i've been in a
sufficient amount of
of rem state and nrem deep state all of
that
my whole experience of my life is
completely different
from those nights where i struggle and
wake up and had maybe six
and just not so good like everything
from
you know mentally emotionally physically
product
productivity wise like every single
there is nothing that is not
positively impacted by having a really
good night of sleep and yet it's
for me we'll get into this later but you
know replicating that day in day out
becomes tricky yeah and it is a hard
thing you know and i think
one of the lessons i learned from um
publishing the book
you know at the time i um i think the
book came out in 2017
and i it took about four years to write
so prior to that sleep was really the
neglected stepsister in the health
conversation of today
and i was so
i was so upset by the suffering that was
happening in society
caused by this global sleep loss
epidemic
and as a consequence you know i was
almost a little bit heavy-handed i think
in sort of dishing out some of these
facts and and i have to be honest i have
to
speak the truth of the science as well
but
for certain people that almost made them
sort of more anxious you know
particularly for people with insomnia
who of course would come to a book
called why we sleep the book wasn't
called how to cure
your insomnia but i'm sure of course
they're still going to buy that book
and i think i i was i learned my lesson
to offer some kind of preface regarding
that
that you know this book is going to be
very triggering and challenging if you
don't sleep well
and therefore when you're not daisy
chaining those nights of good sleep just
as you're describing night after
night and you understand the detriments
of sleep
it can be concerning and i'm the worst
for that you know just like you
i can't string it together now i'm
getting older i'm i'm
i'm well in the foothills of middle age
um
you look fabulous thank you i just had
70 the other day so
it's great um but you know i think it's
that i feel that anxiety and for me it's
terrible because i'm lying in bed awake
i'm realizing that you know my
dorsilateral prefrontal cortex is not
shutting down i'm not releasing this
neurochemical
my cardiovascular system is going to be
this my immune system and at that point
you know you're dead in the water for
the next two years yeah so you become
the sort of like the woody ellen you're
the guy like i'm the guy who's supposed
to have this figured out
that's right yeah and that just shows
you that you know even if you have
you know all of this knowledge um you
know biology can still teach you a few
lessons right
yeah well there's so many directions i
want to take this but i think it
probably would be wise to just
spend a few minutes talking about what
what
like sort of defining our terms like
what is sleep like going through the
various stages and kind of
explaining the terrain yeah so
sleep um in humans at least and uh most
mammals and birds is broadly separated
into two main types that you'd mentioned
on the one hand we have non-rapid eye
movement sleep
or non-rem sleep for short and
non-rem sleep has been further
subdivided into
four separate stages in fact
unimaginatively called stages one
through four
we're a creative bunch clearly asleep
researchers
decreasing in the depth of sleep so
stages three and four are those really
deep stages of restorative sleep that's
what your sort of you know sleep tracker
would say
that's deep sleep stages one and two
they're light sleep
and then on the other hand we have rapid
eye movement sleep or rem sleep
um named not after the popular michael
stipe band for the
1980s but um after these strange
horizontal shuttling eye movements that
occur
under the eyelid as you're in this stage
and rem sleep
is the stage during which we principally
dream
and that's where you have your most sort
of florid most narrative
hallucinogenic emotional sort of dreams
and it turns out that those two types of
sleep non-rem
and rem will play out in this incredible
battle for brain domination throughout
the night
and that um sort of cerebral war
is going to be won and lost every 90
minutes
and then replayed every 90 minutes at
least in humans
and that creates this standard cycling
architecture of sleep
what's fascinating though and we
actually still don't quite understand
why
is that the ratio balance of those two
types of sleep non-rem and rem
changes across the night what i mean by
that is
in the first half of the night the
majority of those
90-minute cycles are comprised of lots
of deep non-rem sleep
but very little rem sleep and so as you
push through to the second half of the
night
now that seesaw balance will actually
shift and instead you get much more
rapid eye movement sleep particularly in
the last couple of hours
and it's not just important to sort of
understand one's
sleep but understanding that structure
has implications real life
so let's say for example that i normally
get my eight hours sort of
and it doesn't you know we can speak
about timing on the clock face and what
makes sense for people but
let's say that i'm a guy who goes to bed
at 10 and i typically wake up at six
but today i've got an early morning
meeting or i want to sort of
cut my sleep short to get a jump start
on the day to get to the gym
and i wake up two hours early so i wake
up at four
rather than six how much sleep have i
lost
well i've lost two hours from eight
hours so i've lost
25 percent of my sleep well yes and no
yes i've lost 25 percent of my total
sleep
but because rem sleep comes late in the
morning i may have lost
50 60 maybe even 70 percent of all of my
rem sleep
so it's not just sort of you know
academic to understand even though
it's fun for me but for for many people
it does have real world
implications the complexity of it is
fascinating i mean it
sleep really is right up there with
outer space and the depths of the ocean
in terms of its it's its mysteries and
you know the the idea that we're just
beginning to learn what's actually going
on
and it's not a matter of i'm sure you
get this question all the time like
what's more important rem sleep or
non-rem sleep or
what you know what's the you know the
sort of significance of being deprived
of one over the other but it's really
the interplay of all of these things
and the more complex you realize it to
be it becomes impossible
to consider that it's not crucial to all
facets of human health
that's right and you know when we go
back to that evolutionary story of
of how you know detrimental sleep is
as a state and it is let's let's face it
you know if there were any stage of
sleep that were not
important that mother nature could have
come in and excised
and had you you know doing all of these
benefits of wakefulness
i'm quite sure she would have and what
we've learned
is that every stage of sleep is
important different stages of sleep
perform different functions for the
brain and body
at different times of night and so yeah
i'll often get that question people will
say
how can i get more deep sleep or how can
i get more rem sleep
and you know i often say well why do you
want more of that and they say well
isn't that the good stuff and
the they're both absolutely critical now
i
could make a scientific argument
that rem sleep could be a little bit
more important from
a simple mortality state because there
were studies
done back in the 1980s with rats and
they've actually never been
replicated again i found them difficult
to read i do
research in humans i don't do animal
research
and i think they won't be replicated for
good reason what they wanted to do
is see if a lack of sleep is deathly
is a lack of sleep fatal and they had
three different flavors of the
experiment
in the first they took rats and they
just deprived them of sleep
you know night and day after day night
and day after day and what they found is
that those rats died
within about 20 days so in other words
rats will die as quickly from a lack of
food as they will from a lack of sleep
that's how
fundamental it is then the two
additional flavors of the experiment
they selectively deprive them of either
just rapid eye movement sleep so that
they could get
just non-rem or they did the opposite
they just deprived them of
non-rem and gave them rem and firstly
both of those were fatal but what was
interesting is that
the rats died from rem sleep deprivation
within about
30 to 40 days and they died from
deep non-rem sleep deprivation within
about 50 or 60 days
so if we want to sort of do a coke pepsi
challenge between sort of you know
non-rem
and rem which one wins out in the
mortality
battle it seems to be rem sleep
and to me that's interesting too if
you'd asked me
where i would place my bets i would have
said non-rem
the reason is because non-rem came first
if you look during
sort of the time course of evolution of
across
phylogeny non-rem sleep was the first
sleep to emerge
and it was only when we went from
reptiles amphibians and fish
and then there was that bifurcation to
birds and then mammals
did the evolution of rem sleep emerge so
rem sleep is the new kid on the
evolutionary block
and furthermore rem sleep evolved twice
independently in birds and mammals which
i find you know it's fascinating too
so to come back to your point i'm sorry
i'm drifting but
all stages of sleep are critical um no
one stage of sleep you can do without
without
suffering detriment right it is
fascinating that sleep deprivation is
fatal and
you talk about this in the book there
used to be before they were outlawed
these contests people would see how long
they could go without sleep
and there's one case study that i recall
from the book where
the guy went mad and then literally i
don't know how long it took him like
10 days or something like that before he
passed away eight
well there were two things that firstly
you write that there was
um they used to guinness um the world
book of records used to
recognize record attempts at
insufficient sleep um and then as the
evidence mounted as to how deleterious a
lack of sleep is
they found it medically you know
impossible to recognize and ethically
impossible to recognize
so guinness no longer recognizes
any attempt to break the world record
for a lack of sleep
and you know to put that in context we
think of you know um
felix baumgardner that incredible uh
austrian who
went up in the red bolts of space
capsule as it were
and when when he ascended the outer
atmosphere of the planet
he opened up his door and he leapt out
and then he hurtled back down to earth
and i believe he broke the sound barrier
with his own body
now guinness says that's fine but
depriving yourself of sleep no no no so
that's
the relative sort of aspect that we're
thinking about there was
um a famous case of a radio disc jockey
in new york
uh in the 1950s called peter tripp and
he wanted to try and break the world
record which was going eight days
straight without sleep
and he was doing this for the march of
dimes and he would sort of
sit in times square and he was going to
do this players spin his records and
after three days he was hallucinating
and he was psychotic
after five days he believed that people
were trying to poison him
and that the secret service was coming
to get him right
um and then he did apparently break the
world record
um he went eight days straight without
sleep and then
he slept for a little over 20 hours he
woke up he ordered his papers
had his breakfast and people said oh it
seems to be back to normal
but trip was no longer trip after that
he started to have problems at work he
got caught up in what was called the
payola scandal
where people were sort of paying djs
under the the desk to play their tracks
um his marriage fell apart and the last
people heard was that he was selling
books door-to-door in the midwest
wow um and so you can you're attributing
that to this
crazy experiment that he did well that
that was the belief now other people i
should know
have gone past his level of sleep
deprivation
and although they went through the same
experience during the lack of sleep
psychosis memory loss emotional
instability they seem to go back to
normal so i think what's happening here
i'm sure we'll come on to sleep and
mental health at some point
in those people who are in that
vulnerable
range where they haven't crossed the
threshold of mental ill health
but they're right there and anything
that pushes them past it be a traumatic
event
be it a difficult divorce or a long
stretch of no sleep
can actually pull that trigger and send
them over that
sort of teetering precipice down into a
state of
prolonged mental ill health right
um that's wild but those those are kind
of fringe cases
in the sense that people are you know
doing this wacky kind of thing
but the more relatable you know
prevalent situation
is chronic sleep deprivation which i
don't know what the statistics are i'm
sure you do of how many people
just on a day-in day-out basis are not
getting enough sleep and how that plays
out
long-term in terms of their physical
mental emotional health
yeah it's quite shocking and i guess
this is sort of the insomnia disclaimer
if
you prefer to sort of listen away but um
firstly what we know is that one out of
every three people that you pass on the
street
is not getting the sleep that they need
so the cdc right now
recommends stipulates a minimum of seven
hours of sleep
to maintain human health
and it doesn't as you said most people
are not pulling all-nighters
frequently or trying to break world
records but it doesn't take that you
know we've already mentioned
the daylight savings experiment i'll
just give you a few other examples
if i take a healthy young male and i
limit them to let's say four or five
hours of sleep
for a couple of nights their level of
testosterone
drops to someone who is 10 years their
senior
so a lack of sleep well age a man by a
decade
in terms of that critical aspect of
wellness and and virility
and we see equivalent impairments in
female reproductive health
by the way follicular stimulating
hormone abnormal menstrual cycles
difficulty in conceiving
so that's hormones that go awry
we also know for example that if i were
to take you
and put you on a diet of let's just say
four hours of sleep a night for a couple
of nights
at the end of those four nights
your blood sugar levels would be so
disrupted
that your doctor would classify as being
pre-diabetic that's crazy
which you know stuns me and to to induce
that kind of a deficit a 40
deficit in your sort of glucose
optimization you would have to gain
about
20 pounds of obese mass within four days
or you could do it by under sleeping wow
we also know for example that if you're
not getting
sufficient sleep in the week before you
get your flu shot you produce
less than 50 percent of the normal
antibody response
i'm sure we'll discuss that when we
speak about immunity
um there was a there was an amazing
experiment though done by some
colleagues in the united kingdom
and they put healthy participants
through two different conditions in one
condition they were limited to
six hours of sleep a night for one week
and then they were given a full
eight hour opportunity for one week and
then they
measured the change in their gene
activity profile
relative to when they were getting
sufficient sleep and there were
two striking findings the first was that
a sizable and significant
711 genes were distorted
in their activity caused by that lack of
sleep and this is not
dramatic sleepless this is yeah i mean
most six hours six hours i'm good that's
that's pretty good right
and that just doesn't seem to be the
case biologically
what was also interesting however was
that about half of those genes
were actually increased in their
activity or what we call overexpressed
the other half were decreased or
switched off in their activity
now those genes that were suppressed
caused by a lack of sleep
were numerous genes associated with your
immune system
yet those genes that were actually
increased in their activity
were genes that were associated with the
promotion of tumors
genes that were associated with cellular
stress and as a consequence
cardiovascular disease
and genes that were associated also with
metabolism and changes in metabolism
and what that study taught me at least
is that there is no aspect
of our physiology that seems to be able
to retreat at the sign of sleep
deprivation and get away unscathed
yeah one of the one of the striking
things in the book that really hit me
was
the relative lack of elasticity in the
human body in that
just one night of dysregulated sleep a
week
has much more of a profound deleterious
effect than you would think you would
think like well i sleep pretty well most
nights but you know
once a week like my stuff got screwed up
but you know i'll recover
but the downstream implications of just
a little bit of dysregulation are much
more
serious than one one would suspect
yeah i mean a good example is another
study where if you take
uh healthy adults and you limit them to
just four hours of sleep for a single
night
the next day we see a 70 drop in
critical anti-cancer fighting immune
cells
7-0 called natural killer cells
now today you and i have both produced
cancer cells more than likely what
prevents
those cells from becoming and
manifesting as the condition that we
call cancer
is in part these critical cancer
fighting immune cells natural killer
cells
that is a dramatic state of immune
deficiency
and it happens quickly after just one
bad night of sleep
you know so you can imagine the state of
your immune system after weeks if not
months
of insufficiency sorry to interrupt the
flow we'll be right back with more
awesome but
i want to snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of
nutrition the thing is most people i
know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes
into their daily routine sadly however
without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to
tackle and solve this very common
problem
the solution we've devised i'm proud to
say is the plant power meal planner our
affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for
nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable
super delicious and easy to prepare
plant-based recipes
everything integrates with automatic
grocery delivery and you get access to
our amazing
team of nutrition coaches seven days a
week and
many other features to learn more and to
sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering 10
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code
rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee
again that's meals.richroll.com promo
code
rrhealth for ten dollars off an annual
membership
all right let's get back to the show
yeah one of the things that that is very
vivid
in the book as well is this is this uh
process that takes place when you're
sleeping this kind of detoxification
process right where you're kind of
cleansing
the brain and washing out the beta
amyloids and all the
kind of negative things that accumulate
in the mind
throughout the day because wakefulness
is really the toxic state right and it's
sleep
that is the restorative state obviously
yeah and you
likened it to the island of manhattan
where all the
skyscrapers shrink and like a wave
washes over them and cleans all of them
and all this
nasty stuff that we don't want is washed
away
and when you impede that process
those things start to accumulate right
and that's why we see
so many of these downstream uh
you know diseases cropping up everything
from alzheimer's diabetes cardiovascular
disease etc
yeah i mean from the perspective of your
brain you know
this sounds a little bit extreme but
biologically i think it's accurate that
wakefulness is low level brain damage
and sleep is sanitary salvation
and this i think is one of the most
exciting areas in sleep science over the
past five years it's just ballooned and
we've been fortunate enough to do some
of this work
which is the relationship between a lack
of sleep and alzheimer's disease
and it really is has become a four-part
story
which is association causation
mechanism and then treatment hope
so what we understood about four or five
years ago
is that people who are typically
sleeping uh less than six hours a night
went on to develop far more of those
sticky toxic
protein elements that are the culprits
underlying alzheimer's disease
called beta amyloid and more recently
this thing called tau protein they're
the two proteins that we believe
underlie the condition of alzheimer's
disease
then what we also found is that people
who have sleep disorders such as
insomnia or sleep apnea
also have a significantly higher risk of
going on to develop alzheimer's disease
later in life
but they're just associations they don't
prove causality
and then several years after that
scientists
demonstrated that if you take a healthy
adult and you deprive them of sleep for
just one night
or you deprive them of just deep sleep
for one night
you see an immediate escalation in that
alzheimer's protein beta amyloid
circulating in the bloodstream
circulating in the cerebrospinal fluid
and also within the brain itself using
brain imaging technology
so that proved causality that you can
take an otherwise healthy person take
away that thing called sleep
and you can trigger that instigation of
what seems to be like the emergence of
an alzheimer's cascade in pathology
if that's true then we ask the question
well what is it about sleep
that de-escalates that alzheimer's
disease
protein in the brain and there was just
i mean this is i think it's nobel prize
worthy but
i'm a researcher called macon nedergaard
at the university of rochester made
three remarkable discoveries she was
looking at mice and what happened when
they slept
and the first thing that she discovered
is that the brain
has a cleansing system and we didn't
think it did
now we knew that the body had its own
cleansing system which everyone will
know about called the lymphatic system
but we didn't think the brain did and
she discovered in fact it does have a
cleansing system
called the glymphatic system named after
the glial cells that make up this this
process
right and those those live in between
the brain cells right that's right yeah
glial is sort of if you look at the
latin and greek
sort of derivative the entomology is the
glue because we used to think that they
were just the cells that kind of
glued the actual brain cells though well
they're all
brain cells technically but would glue
the neurons together
but they are they sort of outnumber
your neurons by many fold and they're
critical they perform lots of functions
but they form this network this sewage
system so that was the first discovery
then she found
that that cleansing system wasn't always
switched on
in high flow volume across the 24-hour
period
instead it was when those mice were
asleep and when they went into deep
sleep
that that sewage system really kicked
into high gear
the final discovery and that's what
makes it relevant to alzheimer's disease
is that she found that one of the
metabolic byproducts one of the pieces
of metabolic detritus
that that sleep was washing away was
this toxic protein
of beta-amyloid and just last year
scientists in boston
actually found a very similar pulsing
cleansing mechanism in human beings
so that was a mechanism that helped us
realize
how this could all connect together
for me though it may all sound very
depressing just as you mentioned for
yourself and i experienced this
the older that we get typically the
worse our sleep
and the older that we get the greater
our risk of alzheimer's disease
and so it may sound quite a depressing
story but i think there's a silver
lining here
because unlike many of the other factors
that are associated with aging and
alzheimer's disease
for example changes in the physical
structure of the brain or even changes
in the the blood flow dynamics of the
brain
they're fiendishly difficult to treat
and in medicine we have no good
wholesale approaches but that sleep is a
missing piece in the explanatory puzzle
of aging and alzheimer's disease is
exciting because maybe we can do
something about it
perhaps what we could do is in
midlife which is when we start to see
the decline of deep sleep
that's when we could intervene with
optimization of sleep with lots of
different methods that are being
developed
and in that way could we bend the arrow
of alzheimer's disease risk down on
itself
could we shift from a model of what we
have right now which is late stage
treatment to mid-life prevention
you know going from a model of sicker to
actually healthcare
that's one of our sort of moonshot goals
i'm incredibly excited
yeah i mean that's the that's the holy
grail right yeah
and i think about this all the time when
i wake up after an amazing night of
sleep
and then my experience throughout the
day is optimal
and then the following night i have a
degraded version of that and i wake up
and i think why can't i just
why can't we figure out a way to
replicate this day in and day out
without pharmaceutical intervention like
i'm trying to do all the right things
and yet
it is so elusive and part of that yes is
age because when you're a teenager you
can just
you know fall asleep in an instant and
seem to get a good night's sleep no
matter what
but i'm constantly thinking about like
how do you
figure this out and master it because if
you could
it would literally change everybody's
lives yeah
and you know if you take the reverse of
that we know you know starting with this
recommended sweet spot of between seven
to nine hours a night
going in the downward direction there's
a very simple truth which is that the
shorter your sleep the shorter your life
short sleep predicts or cause mortality
right which is
which is so ironic given that you know
the hustle culture
you know it's all about maximizing those
daylight hours and i'll sleep when i'm
dead
right i'm just working that death yeah
it's it's
you know it's mortally unwise advice
anyone who tells you that
um but to me i think you know
sleep sleep could be seen
as the swiss army knife of health you
know whatever ailment that you're facing
sleep normally has a tool in the box
that can help
and so for me i think the
the shangri-la is perhaps less about
trying to elongate
lifespan sorry um lifespan sorry
then it is really about prolonging
people's health span
because when you ask most people that's
what they really want when they're
trying to sort of
you know live a clean healthy lifestyle
lifestyle
they don't want a life with disease and
sickness
but when you are starting to short
change your brain and your body of sleep
that's what you're inviting you know and
the elastic band of sleep deprivation
will stretch only so far before it snaps
and if you fight biology normally you
lose and the way you know you've lost is
disease and sickness yeah
the the human hubris over all of this
though is something to behold because we
always think we can find a
you know an end run around these things
and as beautiful and
and magnificent as the scientific method
is it tends to be very binary in its
approach right so
if x then y um controlling for variables
but when you're dealing with systems
that are so complex
my sense is that oftentimes it leads to
unintended negative consequences right
like
this pill and you'll sleep well but
we're not realizing or looking at all
these other things that are occurring
and it isn't until much later when
researchers like yourself
can pull pull the covers on that and say
this was not such a good idea
yeah polakova's no no pun intended right
right right you know but but i think
you're right there is a very
understandable again i i don't want to
sort of be finger wagging or chastise
people if you don't know the science of
sleep
you know i would be just as unknowing
but it took mother nature 3.6 million
years
to put this essential thing called you
know a seven to nine hour sleep need in
place
to think that with hubris or arrogance
that we could come along and within
five or ten years if we're you know
medical sort of forcing medical
residents to go through these ridiculous
sort of schedules or you know if you're
in some other professional industry
that you can just find a way to hack
that
system is unfortunately misfounded
um the stuff that you said about
alzheimer's and dementia makes a lot of
sense but how does that work with
cardiovascular disease i mean obviously
brain health is vascular health
and heart health certainly is vascular
health but what is the
relationship between sleep sleep quality
and you know taking an insurance policy
out against
heart disease yeah i mean so we we
mentioned the
daylight savings time example but more
than that we know that people who are
typically sleeping
less than six hours a night on average
will have about a 200 percent
increased risk of cardiovascular disease
or
a heart attack uh in their lifetime um
we also know from a prospective study
that came out of harvard medical school
that and they took a a large range of
people who had
no pre-existing signs of cardiovascular
disease
and then they tracked them across five
or six years
and what they found is that those people
who are sleeping
less than six hours a night they had a
200 to 300 percent increased risk of
calcification of the coronary artery and
that coronary artery is
essentially that's the you know the
corridor
of life for your heart when you hear
people saying gosh they had a massive
coronary
what they mean is that that coronary
artery had become blocked calcification
and that's exactly what we see now again
this was a prospective city no one had
any signs of that before
but when you looked at that sleep
shaving at sleep coming down and down
that was the predictive factor we also
know that
however sort of turning the tables in
the positive
why does sleep give you that benefit
during
deep sleep our heart rate decelerates
our vascular system our vessels start to
relax
you can think of deep sleep like the
very best form of blood pressure
medication that you could
ever wish for we also see that it's
during
that night time phase when we drop
levels of cortisol
which otherwise if left in high
concentrations is a stress related
chemical it's an adaptive chemical too
we all need cortisol
but if you're just chronically high in
cortisol
that is you know deathly for your
cardiovascular system
and sleep will actually ratchet down
that level
also sleep will quiet the fight or
flight branch of your nervous system
it's called the sympathetic nervous
system which i think is terribly named
it's anything but
sympathetic you know it's agitating it's
aggravating
and it's during deep sleep that
we actually shift over from that fight
or flight branch
to the more quiescent calming branch
called the parasympathetic nervous
system
and so now we can start to understand
why we see
risks for heart attack risks for
cardiovascular
disorder we published a paper a couple
of months ago demonstrating that short
sleep and
particularly not just short sleep but
also fragmented sleep and this is i
think another important point that we've
learned in the
most recent years it's not just about
the quantity of sleep
it's also about the quality of that
sleep
and we found that people who had
fragmented sleep
had a higher likelihood of their blood
vessels become
becoming hard it's what we call
atheroscle sclerosis
the hardening of the blood vessels which
can then be a direct pathway to
cardiovascular disease
and heart attack as well that's
interesting
um and does that is there a sense of
um where that falls in the pecking order
of
importance when you compare it to
nutrition or exercise or these other
kind of contributing or ameliorating
factors with respect to heart disease
it's just as heavy a hitter
you know if you look at the combination
of quantity and quality of sleep and you
look at the effect sizes
the you know it's right up there um yeah
you can almost play the game and and i
don't mean to do this because
i'm someone who pays i'm very dedicated
to
a practice of physical activity and
exercise you know i'm not quite at
your level but um and i eat very cleanly
i too am
i'm a vegetarian um so
i respect those things because i know
how utterly important they are for my
health span and my lifespan but i can do
a thought experiment where i say i take
you rich role and i'm going to deprive
you
of either exercise for 24 hours
of food for 24 hours of water for 24
hours
or of sleep for 24 hours and sleep
yeah no there's no comparison but yeah a
country mile
will dwarf the physiological and mental
deficits that come by way of that
i think the only other thing that's
perhaps will overtake sleep is oxygen
you know if i starve you function
you'll you will i hold my hands up i
lose out to oxygen right right
but but you've said often that you know
when you think of the pillars of health
sleep isn't a pillar it's the foundation
upon which all these other pillars
are erected essentially right yeah i
used to think it was i thought
about it pillar but then you know the
the more i've done this research over
the years
the more i realized that i was wrong it
is a foundation on which
those the two things said you know i can
give you a good example
if you're trying to manage your weight
if you're trying to diet let's say and
lose weight
but you're not getting sufficient sleep
of all the weight that you lose will
come from lean muscle matte
mass sorry and not fat right the body
when it's fatigued
in that way wants to hold on to those
fats exactly
your body becomes stingy in giving up
its fat
so in other words when you are under
slept but you're trying to watch your
diet watch what you eat
you will lose what you wanted to keep
which is muscle
and you will gain what you wanted to
lose which is fat
right and on top of that that's when
those crazy cravings for terrible foods
happen
right i just know when i'm when i'm
under slept
that's when i start thinking about all
these foods that you know i shouldn't
eat
and it comes by way of two different
routes and they're non-mutually
exclusive one is a brain root the other
is a body root
what we've firstly discovered is that
when you're not getting sufficient sleep
you know it be it
six hours a night five hours a night
four hours a night for several nights
there are two critical appetite
regulating hormones that go awry
and these hormones are called leptin and
ghrelin
lept i sometimes joke that they sound
like hobbits but that's just my british
tolkien
obsession but um leptin is the hormone
of satiety
when you release leptin it says to your
brain and your body you're full with
what you've just eaten
you don't want to eat anymore you're no
longer hungry
ghrelin is the opposite ghrelin is the
hunger hormone
it says no no you're not satisfied with
your food and you want to eat more
and when you are under slept those
hormones go in the opposite direction in
ways you don't wish them to
firstly leptin which is the satiety
signal
that drops away so you lose that signal
of being
full and you constantly feel hungry if
that weren't bad enough by itself
ghrelin the hunger hormone that actually
increases
so now you may have eaten a standard
meal that normally otherwise
otherwise would have been satisfying but
it doesn't feel satisfying and you still
want to eat more
and on average people will typically eat
anywhere between two to four hundred
extra calories
each day under these conditions of
insufficient sleep
what was also striking from these
studies is not just that you want to eat
more
which in general you do and you want to
snack more
but it's what it is that you have a
craving for
because when you are under slept you
have this increase
particularly a dominant increase in
wanting to eat those
heavy-hitting carbohydrates
also sugars as well as salty snacks
all of those are foods that we know in
excess will put you on a path towards
this obesogenic profile
right it would be interesting to take a
look at
uh the whether or not the rate of
people going to the drive-through
increases on daylight
daylight savings right on that day when
everybody's lost an hour of sleep
they're a little bit more tired
i would suspect it would follow that a
lot of people are you know hitting
mcdonald's on the way to work i wish i
could get that data
you know i wish there was like a
mcdonald's app where i could look at the
usage statistics
and then do that sort of you know study
um
so in the body that's part of the reason
but in the brain
there is also a pathway and we did a
study several years ago where we took a
group of healthy adults of normative
weight
and we either gave them a full night of
sleep or we took sleep away for a night
and then we put them and same
individuals so it's the same people
going through two different studies
and inside of the brain scanner we were
showing them these different food items
and they had to rate how desirable those
food items were
and we made this a little bit more real
by saying look at the end of this brain
scan we're going to pull you out i'm
going to give you one of those foods
so that you have to eat it so you know
they're not just saying oh okay i should
just be good and i know that
you know that i should say is nice um
and what we found firstly is that people
when they were under slept their hunger
increased
firstly um sorry that was obviously
secondly what we found is that
they were rating you know junk foods
as far more desirable as a consequence
and then when we looked at the brain
scan something fascinating happened
there were the deep hedonic emotional
centers of the brain
they were revved up as a consequence of
a lack of sleep
these sort of impulsive sort of you know
almost these addictive brain sensors in
fact they they are a part of the same
centers that go awry in addiction
what was also interesting is that other
parts of the brain particularly apart
right upstairs above your eyes
in the frontal lobe that had shut down
which normally keeps our hedonic desires
in check and as a consequence the
underslept
people were sort of no longer reaching
for leafy greens and a handful of nuts
they were reaching for ice cream pizzas
these salty snacks
etc so it's both within your brain
that explains why you know for a fact
you know
when i'm not sleeping i'm just i'm
always hungry
right i can never get satisfied i can
never get full and i don't know why it
is
brain and body well i see i i i feel
seen and hurt because
as somebody who's been in recovery for a
long time i you know in an end of one
experiment
i know when i'm under slept or i've had
a terrible night of sleep
all of those kind of addictive
compulsions you know because i have some
self-awareness around them i'm able to
like understand that that's what's
happening but it's always been confusing
that it correlates like why do i
like feel like acting out or eating this
thing or you know
like sending the email i shouldn't send
or all of these things that happen when
i'm
when i'm under slept that's very
interesting yeah and thanks for bringing
that up to about uh addiction disorders
we've done a little bit of work in this
area too um
what we found is that um when we
shortchange someone's sleep these
dopamine centers within the brain that
are what we think of as reward based
sensors and they're the centers in the
brain that addiction
will hijack those become increased in
their sensitivity so your reward
sensitivity increases
your risk taking increases your
impulsivity
increases what we know is that those
people who are
under slept are far more likely to
develop
an addiction disorder during use we also
know and this is perhaps even
stronger of a relationship when you are
trying to abstain and go through
recovery sleep is a huge predictive
factor
when you're getting enough sleep your
chances of remitting and recovering
are far higher than when you're not
getting sufficient sleep yeah that makes
sense
well this is a this is a good
opportunity for me to indulge you in
my own history here yeah um because
you know just reading reading your book
again and getting ready for today
i started thinking more more profoundly
and deeply about my
own history with sleep over the years
and i just i had this like
dawning depressing epiphany of just how
sleep-deprived i i have been up until
like literally my late 30s with how i've
lived my life i mean i
from age like 14 to 21 i was a
competitive swimmer i was waking up
throughout junior high school in high
school at 4 45 every day to go to swim
practice for two hours then i go to
school then i go to some practice again
for two more hours do my homework
go to bed repeat chronically sleep
deprived through
those years going to college the same
thing
and just you know i have memories of
just sleepwalking through my life just
so exhausted not just from the sleep
deprivation but
on top of that like very rigorous
training right so
yeah i literally had no energy for
anything
and then around 21 is when my alcoholism
really started to kick
in so the next 15 years uh was a cycle
a progressive cycle of course of you
know
sleeping sort of drinking to to blackout
you know passing out
you know going on three-day benders
and then experiencing those sleepless
nights that occur
in the wake of that it would take three
or four days to normalize and
terrible nights of laying in bed
sweating and staring at the ceiling and
unable to sleep and
the you know shaking and the whole thing
only to finally get
you know by wednesday getting one good
night of sleep feeling okay and then
repeating
and repeating it again right yeah and i
did that for
15 years and it wasn't i got sober 31
and then i transferred a lot of my
addictive tendencies on on to
workaholism so it didn't get that much
better but looking back
it's just unbelievable how much i
shortchanged myself from
sleep and i think what is the
relationship between
that early sleep deprivation and my
alcoholism
what is the relationship between the
alcoholic sleep deprivation
and my ability to be a functional human
and all i can tell you is that when i
look back i think back on those years
i could barely remember a single book
that i read i couldn't tell you anything
that i learned in law school
i barely remember college and my memory
overall is not so good
yeah it's really like unbelievable when
i think about
how profound that is and the impact that
it's had on out of my life on top of
that
this is separate but i slept walked like
all the time when i was a kid
ultimately i grew out of that but yeah i
don't know how that plays into it but
when you hear that like what is your
what is your reaction yeah so i you know
firstly from the memory
point that you mentioned um we know that
sleep
is critical for learning and memory in
at least three different ways that
we can speak about but what about the
long-term consequences of that well
we have a little bit of data from
the situation of airline pilots right
who typically you know have to undergo
jet lag they're chronically sleep
deprived
and firstly what scientists found when
they looked at
matching those pilots with sort of
someone of similar age some
civil background education lifestyle et
cetera et cetera
they found that parts of their brain had
actually shrunk
it's what we call atrophy they lost
brain cells where had they lost brain
cells
they'd lost them particularly in the
memory centers of the brain a structure
that we call the hippocampus
and the hippocampus which sits on the
left and the right side of your brain
like a long cigar shape on the left and
the right side it's almost like the
informational
inbox of your brain it's very good at
receiving new information and memories
and holding onto them
and that part of the brain had actually
deteriorated
because of that disrupted sleep schedule
now
you could argue well perhaps it's just
something about
bias selection that you know
i i don't know how it would be but it
was going to airline pilots
yeah because of poor memory they don't
go into profession x they go into pi
now piloting is essential with memory
and so i don't think that's the case
but a better demonstration of that was
then they looked at how long that they'd
been on the job
how many years had they been going
through that
that sort of sleep deficiency and that
predicted the magnitude of brain
shrinkage
which made me think okay it i think it's
more likely that it has to do with the
sleep as well
so is there a potential long-term
organic
atrophy consequence of insufficient
sleep on the brain
we seem to think that there is yes but
again i think i want to be
really careful here and i don't want to
be
causing people alarm and what i would
say is that it is
never too late to start sleeping better
and that's not just me sort of pulling
out the pom-poms and trying to be
positive
we've got data so in a series of studies
and we've done a lot of work in as i
mentioned in
older adults but if you take a group of
mid-life adults who are suffering from
untreated sleep apnea heavy snoring and
then you put them on treatment which is
called a cpap
machine c um cpap
the continuous positive airway pressure
and by the way if anyone's listening to
this and they think that they suffer
from
uh sleep apnea or they have a partner
who does please go and get diagnosed it
is a deathly disease untreated
and what they found is that about half
of those participants complied to the
treatment
and about half didn't and they tracked
them over a 10-year period
and what they found is that those
individuals who complied to the
treatment
and whose sleep was improved as a
consequence
they staved off the onslaught of
alzheimer's disease and cognitive
decline
by anywhere between 10 to 15 years
relative to those who remained untreated
or uncompliant with their treatment
in other words even in mid-life there is
evidence to say it's never too late to
start sleeping
but can those those brain centers that
that have atrophied be regenerated or
is that a permanent thing we don't know
uh it
depends on what extent of atrophy we do
we used to think
uh maybe 30 years ago that the brain
didn't produce new brain cells once it
had matured and once you were an adult
um that was your sort of smorgasbord of
brain cells
and as you lost them through time when
you drink you kill brain cells they
never come back they never come back
yeah well that's not true
there are in many regions of the brain
that is true but there are a couple of
regions that
it's not true and in fact these memory
centers the hippocampus
that's one of the centers that does
actually seem to have some degree of
regenerative capacity
you know how how capable
of meeting the demand of brain atrophy
and damage
that that system is of regeneration
is unclear what i should note by the way
is that that system
of of the creation of new brain cells
it's what we call neurogenesis
um which i think is a great alternative
name for a band rather than just genesis
um phil um you know
if you deprive a rat of of sleep
it fails to have the regulation of that
neurogenesis you lose the capacity for
neurogenesis when you are underslept
so it becomes this self-fulfilling
negative vicious cycle of prophecy
that if you are not getting sufficient
sleep those brain cells start to
deteriorate and atrophy and then the one
thing that could help you get them back
is the one thing that you keep depriving
yourself of
so you lose even the salvation of the
sort of the salvaging sorry i should say
of that yeah
wow um you mentioned pilots traveling
from
time zone to time zone on top of that i
want to talk about
the medical profession because here in
you know
lie the greatest irony these people who
are dispatched with
you know tending to our health have this
you know complete myopic perspective
when it comes to prioritizing sleep in
their own profession and there's this
um systemic you know kind of
infrastructure setup
that prioritizes lack of sleep these
residents who have to work these 30-hour
shifts
this legacy of an old tradition that was
set in stone
long ago and continues like unbelievably
to
you know be the standard operating
procedure today
which is unbelievable and i loved how
you
told the history of this this guy
halstead right yeah
who who basically was a hard ass back in
the at the turn of the century and just
said this is the way we're gonna do it
and today we still do it in the manner
that
that that he kind of established back
then but it turns out he was like a
raging cocaine addict
that's right yeah so william halstead
was the guy who set up the uh the
resident the first resident uh training
program in the united states
um at johns hopkins university um
and you know it's called a residency for
a reason because you're going to become
a resident
you're going to live in the hospital
right and
he was known for being able to go these
heroic long stretches without needing
sleep
people were stunned and he expected his
junior residents
to match him in that and gradually
after his death it emerged the reason
why he was
able to do that holsted in his early
career was actually studying
the anesthetic properties of
cocaine and unfortunately he started to
use cocaine himself and he become he
became
an accidental addict and
that was how he was able to just go days
straight
right without seemingly you know needing
sleep
so it apparently set the expectation
that everybody else should be able to
should match
the way that he was to go the same
degree now there were times there were
stories where
people would say you know he would in
the operating theater
he would have to go and take a break
because he was saying he was not feeling
well he was sweating a lot he seemed to
be cold and he would have to go take a
break and you know
because he was detoxing during the long
surgery so he had to go and administer
again
um and there were even stories so
he knew that he was an addict and he
sought
to go into rehab under a different
surname and at the time they were
treating
cocaine addiction with morphine right
and unfortunately what happened is that
he came out of that rehabilitation
program
with no resolution to his cocaine
addiction but now he had a heroin
addiction right
and the story goes that he would you
know have his
shirts his white shirts sent away to get
laundered in places like
paris you know fran and they would come
back both white and starchy but there
would also be other
you know white related compounds
in the so and we've never let go of that
you know arcane and i think inane
practice
and it's not medical residents who are
at fault here
you know speak to any of them and none
of them will tell you
that that's what i want to be doing yeah
um
you know and i i've had conversations
with a dear friend called peter
tier who is who went through the medical
practice his wonderful medical doctor
and he describes you know some shocking
history with
a lack of sleep and the statistics are
just damning firstly what we know is
that medical residents
who have performed a 30-hour shift will
make 460 percent more diagnostic errors
in the intensive care unit
secondly we know that if you're going to
have elective surgery let's say
and your surgeon has slept less than six
hours in the previous 24
they're 170 percent more likely to cause
a major surgical error such as rupturing
a blood vessel
or you know damaging or puncturing an
organ
then the irony is that a medical
resident who's worked a 30 hour shift
when they get back in their car to drive
home at the end of their shift
they're 168 more likely to get into a
car crash
now returning to the accident emergency
room
from which they probably came but now as
a patient
rather than a doctor and
you know i've tried with many other
people to lobby the medical institute
um and or institution
and try to understand why why is this
the case
and i think some of it has to do with
the old boys network that it's almost
like a hazing that you know we went
through it
so you have to do it you know you know
man up suit up boot up woman up
you know you you need to get through
this this is a rites of passage
and again it comes back to that idea
that thinking that you can fight
mother nature and evolution is just
thick headed and that's what this just
yeah i mean i get the idea
that you have to develop a level of
rigor and
emotional resiliency to handle that kind
of job and there is something to be said
for
you know putting people in challenging
situations to see how they
function under high stress but the sleep
deprivation aspect of it is just
ridiculous you know if when you
go through medical school you know you
take an oath which is to do no harm
and then you're placed under conditions
of insufficient sleep that statistically
will guarantee that you will do more
harm than if you were sleeping
or working let's say just a 16-hour
shift yeah you know and one of the push
i think some of the pushback that you
receive or i've received
is look my mind's made up don't confuse
me with the data
right and you think okay you're the
doctor you're the scientist
what can i do you know isn't this
self-evident
and one of the arguments though i think
that has some legitimacy
is that of continuity of care that if
you
are flip-flopping back and forth between
a resident every six hours
the continuity of the patient care can
decrease but then i
i thought about that argument for a long
time and then i looked at
um a number of medical uh country or
sorry the medical systems throughout the
world and i asked
how long does it take to train their
residents and how good
is their medical care and what i found
is that there are places like new
zealand
uh france switzerland they all have
their residents working
no more than 16 hours and
their quality of health care is actually
ranks far better
in the worldwide statistics than the
united states
so you can't tell me that you can't
train an individual within five years or
less
at a reasonable amount of sleep and not
maintain
high quality of medical practice right
well part of the problem tracks back to
the fact that there's no
education on this in medical school
right so these doctors who then become
hospital administrators
don't have the proper background to make
a better decision about this
that's exactly right so i i also you
know myself and some
other researchers um you look at the
medical curriculum
throughout many of these uh world first
world nations
and what you discover is that on average
the average medical resident will
receive somewhere between an
hour and a half to two hours of
education on sleep
relative to the entire medical program
now that strikes me because that's
one-third of their patients lives
and that one-third of their life spent
asleep
makes a profound difference to their
two-thirds of waking
health life why aren't we investing more
in the education of sleep for our
medical residents
well why aren't we have you seen since
the book came out and you've been
you know speaking regularly on this
have you seen changes positive movement
in this regard
a little but not not too much yeah
unfortunately
i think there are some medical programs
around this country at least that are
doing better than
others there's a quite a variability
so some are prioritizing it and
understanding its importance
but overall no i think that that same
sort of some of that hubris
um is still present um
what do we do to change that well you
know i
tried early on speaking about this from
the statistics of
the patients from a point of view of
compassion and empathy for our young
residents
and that sort of just falls on deaf ears
what i realized is that you have to
speak in a currency with which
you know medical institutions and
administrators will listen to which is
dollars and cents and when you start to
rack up the numbers
regarding malpractice suits caused by
insufficient sleep start paying
attention without paying attention
yeah so i was just stupid i i i thought
about
appealing in in the wrong language you
got to follow the money
yeah i know yeah but this uh halstead
reminds me
of uh that tv show the nick
did you watch this show no i did stephen
soderbergh did a limited
um series several years ago i think it
was for
showtime i can't remember um but it's
about
this surgeon played by clive owen at the
turn of the century it's literally 1900
and he is he he's like an opium addict
and then he gets introduced to cocaine
and heroin but he's
he's this talented surgeon and he goes
into the theater and you see the crazy
surgeries that they were doing at the
time it's it's quite an interesting
document i think you would really like
it but
i couldn't help but think i wonder if
this character is modeled after i
suspect
so i suspect if you know drug abuse
cocaine and such was involved then he
was
this extraordinary power and force that
sort of birthed into being you know this
this new way of medical practice i well
imagine it was based on that right
right um well the relationship between
substance
and substance abuse and addiction and
sleep deprivation is another way in on
this
you know in this terrain i mean when
you're when you when you have all these
doctors who are being compelled to stay
up so late they're going to find
exogenous ways of
you know enhancing their ability to do
their jobs and
the treatment center that i went to many
years ago
was known for having lots of doctors and
doctors and pilots like the two people
that you completely
you know sort of divest yourself of any
of all control over to right and yeah
i just remember being struck at how many
surgeons and
violets were in this treatment center
right like there was a
brain surgeon who was a morphine addict
and there was
all kinds of pilots that were addicted
to vicodin there were anesthesiologists
that
were fentanyl addicts you know they
would steal it
when they would not use the entire vial
and and they were using them
primarily so that they could function in
their in their job capacity that's right
yeah that's how it's starting to sort of
try to come you know back
from the disruption right but what we
know is that the
um the risk or the probability
of someone abusing drugs of abuse um
in the medical profession is
significantly higher than the general
population
to me uh more striking and and well
an equally striking and equally
worrisome statistic recently
is that the rates of suicide are
far higher in young residents and what
we've discovered over the past
maybe 10 years and we've been doing a
lot of this work too is the intimate
relationship between sleep and your
mental health
and what we know is that when you are
not getting sufficient sleep
your suicidal thoughts
increase suicidal planning increases
suicide attempts increase and tragically
suicide completion
also increases as well and more
generally what we've discovered
and i've been doing this for about 20
years now we have not been able to
discover a single
psychiatric condition in which sleep is
normal
and so i think sleep is a profound story
to tell
in our understanding our treatment maybe
even our prevention
of grave mental illness well certainly
in saying that it should be the first
stop on the
kind of treatment protocol right like
how is your sleep let's deal with that
first before we look at pharmaceutical
interventions
yeah it's a stabilizing force and we
know it's a stabilizing force both
in terms of your psychology as we
mentioned impulsivity
but also just from a basic reward brain
sensitivity
that your addiction potential from a
brain perspective
is higher with insufficient sleep same
individual
two different sleep conditions two
different
addictive profiles right wow
wow i have to reassess my whole life now
oh i'm so sorry
no no no it's good i want to talk about
uh sleep in in adolescence and in teens
because i think the work that you're
doing here and and the issues that
you're trying to
you know raise awareness around are
super important
the implications of of chronic sleep
deprivation in young people the
relationship
to um you know early school hours and
how this plays out in terms of
academic potential and the mental health
implications that you just mentioned
yeah so there's been a remarkable amount
of work looking at
this issue of early school start times
this incessant model of
marching back the the school clock hours
and the summary of the evidence really i
think it goes
the following firstly we see that um
academic when you shift schools to a
later school start time so when you do a
causal intervention what happens
firstly academic grades increase
attruancy rates
decrease psychological and psychiatric
referrals
also decrease but what we also
discovered
is that the life expectancy of those
students
increased and you may think well hang on
a second
how do you how does that work well
the leading cause of death in late stage
adolescent teens is actually not suicide
it's road traffic accidents and here
sleep matters
enormously and there was one good
example i think it came from
teton county in wyoming they shifted
their school start times from around
7 30 in the morning to just before nine
o'clock in the morning
the only thing more remarkable than the
extra hour of sleep that those kids
reported getting
was the drop in road traffic accidents
that following year after the time
switch
there was a 70 7-0 reduction
in car crashes in students 16 to 18.
statistically unbelievable it blows my
mind now you know
statistically you can give a relevance
to that
think of the advent of abs systems in
cars anti-lock brake systems that stop
your wheels from locking up into
heartbreaking
that dropped accident rates by around 20
to 25 percent
and it was deemed a revolution yet here
is a simple
biological factor giving our kids the
sleep that they need
that will drop accident rates by up to
70 percent
so if our goal as educators truly
is to educate and not risk lives in the
process
then we are failing our children in a
most spectacular manner
with this incessant model of early
school start times
you know when sleep is abundant minds
flourish
when it's not they don't right there's
so much education i think that that
needs to be
done in this area um as a as a parent of
of two teens i've got four kids two
older boys
um any parent knows how difficult it is
to wake up
a young adolescent in the morning and
the frustration that comes with that
but what i've come to better understand
by didn't
of your work is how crucial
sleep is for that developing brain and
during covid we have one child our
younger child who's being homeschooled
right now
we've let her sleep in as long as she
wants
and we don't start her her first class
until
noon and so she's getting a ton of sleep
but
if you tr even tried to wake her up at
nine o'clock i mean
forget it you're going to spend the next
hour and a half trying to get this kid
up
so clearly there's a reason why that
state of sleep is so
deep right like that that it is crucial
in this developing
you know in this developing mind yeah
and
you know we often have that classic idea
of
you know a parent at the weekend pulling
the sheets off
you know the teenager ripping open the
camera saying you know you're
wasting the day you know but
firstly what we know is that it's not
their fault because
during that adolescent transition there
is a biological shift in their 24-hour
rhythm
that they now want to go to bed later
and wake up later
so asking a teenager to wake up at seven
o'clock in the morning
and operate and conduct themselves with
good grace
and be able to learn effectively is like
it's just
an adult you know to wake up at 3 30 or
4 in the morning
and be the best version of yourself you
know if if i was to wake up at you know
three o'clock in the morning and come
through to the kitchen and or
both awake i'd have to say to my partner
you know i would say to look darling
and she would say like why you're so
moody i'm just not the best version of
myself because i've woken up too early
and and she will definitely tell you
that but i think it's
it's the same you know misgiving because
we don't understand how sleep works with
our teenagers and so putting them in the
school
at that time seven or eight in the
morning essentially is
you know educating them amnesic right
they are at that stage they are leaky
sieves
and what will go in will just come out
the other side
so that's the first thing that's
happening it's not their fault it's just
their biology
and then second at the weekend they're
trying to sleep off
a debt that we've lumbered them with
during the week because of these early
school start times
and if you ask parents if you sort of
um question parents of teenagers
what proportion of parents think that
their teen is getting sufficient sleep
and more than 70 of them say i think my
teen is doing fine i think they're
getting the sleep that they need
when in reality less than 15 percent of
those teens
are actually getting the sleep that they
need so there is a
parent-to-child mismatch in sleep
understanding
and as a consequence there is a parent
to child
transmission of sleep neglect they
parents don't see it they don't
understand it
and so you know in 15 or you know 10 or
20 years time
that teenager lo and behold seems to
have amnesia
and they with their own kids will do the
same thing they'll pull the sheets off
and say you're wasting the day because
it was taught to them by their parents
that sleep
and getting the right timing of sleep
and the right amount of sleep
is something shameful so for that
young person do they need more hours
they do so yeah so the eight-hour rule
doesn't really apply
no that's for adults yeah and in fact
the brain
doesn't stop developing until it's about
25 years old and sleep plays a
critical role in what we call brain
plasticity which is
modeling the brain it plays a role early
in life in the first couple of years
um sleep seems to actually help wire up
the brain
so it's almost like sleep at that time
of life comes in
to a new neighborhood and like an
internet service provider
it wires all of those homes with
high-speed fiber optic cables
but then later in life that's when
during the teenage years
we've actually realized which homes are
using the high bandwidth and which homes
aren't really
sort of drawing on that sort of you know
that broad band
speed and so then the role of the brain
it goes from expanding
creating lots of connections which is
called neurogenesis to then actually
synaptic pruning
which is where we now have to make the
brain efficient for adulthood
we sculpt away the unnecessary and we
keep the necessary
and sleep performs that role too in
later teenage years
and as a consequence if you are
chronically undersleeping a teenager
you're effectively stunting brain
development
and no one would wish that for their
child right so you you impede
neurogenesis
so there's there's fewer pathways to
choose from
yeah and then as you age then then
you're you're selecting
you know you're basically you have less
to choose from right so you're just
limiting the brain's capacity to do its
job well
so early in life in the first five or so
years you want to sort of
you know it's almost spray and pray
attitude a little bit like in investing
you just you know gift all regions of
the brain lots of connections
and then you let experience and time
teach the brain which highways and sort
of
trip trees and avenues and lanes would
you like to keep and which should be
removed so
now as you shift later in life it's all
about
efficiency let's get this brain
efficient because right now
when you've got this too much too much
connectivity it's good
to sort of as a general blueprint to lay
down
but then let life tell you which of
those
sort of you know networks you should
enhance and which you should actually
remove and it's later in life that we're
removing those and as i said it's not
until we're about 25 that the brain has
finished all of that maturation
and that's why you know the
recommendation is seven to nine hours in
adults and i would argue
in adults once they're past 25 years old
before that you'd need much more sleep
yeah so
what would be the ideal amount of sleep
for the adolescent or young teen
yeah it's usually somewhere between
eight to ten
hours and you know going up to maybe 11
hours depending on that teen
and if people want to find out there's a
great um informational sheet they can
just go to the national sleep foundation
um it's the national sleep
foundation.org
and you can look at the current
guidelines that we and other scientists
have sort of
tried to gather all of the information
and say look where should we position
these windows of sleep duration based on
different age ranges so it's a great
resource if people are thinking about
that for their kids and
for themselves as well so if you could
if you could bend the year of the
the secretary of education i mean what
would be your recommendation in terms of
school start time like 9 00 a.m i think
for teenagers i would say 10 a.m 10
yeah 10 at the minimum and what's
interesting is that
the younger kids they can actually wake
up earlier because they haven't gone
through that adolescent transition so
you know they probably could be going to
school and learning effectively at let's
say
9 a.m or even 8 30 a.m
but in those studies they carefully
asked the question
we we can't set different times for
different
age brackets you know it's just not
practical
and i understand why
there is resistance in the school system
you can say why
are we starting that early some of it
has to do a little bit with the bus
unions the bus networks that try to get
kids to school
and i get that i get you know it's not
an easy problem to solve
but i also realize that we've put people
on the moon
and i think we can solve this and
tougher problems yeah yeah
and so i'm not trivializing it it's a
it's a big problem and i don't have all
of the answers i'm just the scientist
well there's the there's there's the
kind of mechanistic logistical aspect of
solving that problem but there's
also the mental hurdle which comes with
education right like getting somebody's
head
wrapped around the idea of why a 10 a.m
school start is in
the best interest of the child is a
hurdle
right and you know for most parents
that's that's their genetic legacy
that's what you
you know they're like i gotta get to
work too like what am i supposed to you
know so
right and and that's the hard part so
what they did is they looked at say okay
let's say that we started school at ten
o'clock that's only going to help the
teenagers
but would it hurt the kids who were
younger
because that would then say well we
can't do this one-time fits-all
phenomenon
and what they found is that it didn't
hurt the younger kids they were learning
just as effectively
but in the teenagers they were learning
far more effectively in fact if you look
across the day
and you ask where are those school start
times really hurting the teenagers
it's in the first half of the day
because they're mostly asleep and you
ask any high school teacher
you know what is my what does my class
look like
first thing in the morning versus in the
afternoon they're usually very different
as an audience
what about uh
dealing with um things like
ssris and uh
and treating adhd with adderall and
ritalin
and the over medication of our young
people
and the implication on sleep and brain
development yeah i wrote a little bit
about this in the book
um it is unfortunate that you know if
you look at adhd the current recommended
treatment are things like adderall and
ritalin and they are
some versions of something that looks
very much like amphetamine
and i'm not dismissing the idea that
adhd exists i'm not one of those people
it clearly does
i also am not anti-medication by any
means
but what i would say is that
unfortunately those medications
are very strong wake promoting
medications
i mean if you ask an amphetamine addict
you know if they need
sleep when they're using amphetamines
they will laugh at you
right they'll say don't you kidding me i
can go straight without sleep
and so maybe we need to think
differently about at least the timing
of that medication you know do we want
to be medicating kids in the morning or
in the evening
because if those things are weak
promoting we know that kids with adhd
have non-normal sleep they actually have
disrupted sleep
and we're also starting to find that
those medications themselves
are sleep disruptors and so one wonders
what would be the efficacy the benefit
of those medications
which there are but just timed correctly
and you are at least able to try and
protect sleep or what if we could just
come up with better medications that
aren't
so destructive to sleep i think that to
me would be a better approach
is there is there research on uh uh
antidepressant medication like the ssris
and the implications for
sleep there are yeah so sleep is usually
not normative
when you're taking antidepressants now
that's a general statement and it's too
general
in fact it really depends on which type
of antidepressant
because different antidepressants will
shift different neurochemical systems in
the brain so
ssris stands for selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor
and serotonin is a key neurochemical in
the regulation
of sleep we have found historically that
people taking antidepressants will
typically have a reduction in rem sleep
it really seems to hit hard
on rem sleep and as we
we may come on to discuss um sleep and
particularly rem sleep
provides a form of emotional first aid
rem sleep is what i've described as
overnight therapy and there's nothing
that i've seen that you know sort of is
that much
further from its effect size based on
the evidence
and so one wonders whether or not we can
look to
alternative medications that again have
at least some conceptual sensitivity
to the things that regulate sleep and
try to stay away from disrupting sleep
you know if sleep offers some form of
assistance to depression and we know
that insufficient sleep
predicts depression we know that
people who are depressed don't sleep
very well they have abnormal sleep
patterns
so if sleep is a part of that disorder
and disordered sleep is a part of
depression
then shouldn't we think about the
medications that they take
that are also sleep disruptive and maybe
think about finding ways where we time
again the the onset of the medication i
don't know how many doctors describe to
their patients
not just take two of these but when you
know seven o'clock in the morning
could be very different than seven
o'clock in the evening in fact that's
true of many medications in terms of
their sleep disruptive capacity yeah
for for somebody who who for whatever
reason
schedule wise or or whatnot can't seem
to carve out the eight hours of sleep a
night
um can this be made up for
through napping or biphasic or
polyphasic sleep like there's there
always seems to be people who are doing
all kinds of experiments with polyphasic
sleep but
to my mind i mean you know obviously
more way more than i do but it seems
like those
experiments always like somebody's like
i'm just gonna sleep every
two hours every four hours but that
never lasts very long right they always
end up going
back it doesn't so this sort of idea of
what's called highly polyphasic sleep
uh some people will describe it as the
uberman sort of schedule some people
have said yeah
self-optimization right biohacking
yeah it doesn't work right not again no
it really doesn't and
you know there is there is nothing in
our biology
that would suggest that's how we should
be sleeping and in fact it's quite the
opposite
in fact there's a lot in our biology
screaming you should not
be sleeping like that you're not
designed to be highly polyphasic
in your sleep meaning multiple bouts of
sleep
you know the only time that we do that
is when we're infants
you know and it's sort of i think billy
crystal is a longtime insomniac he's got
this joke and he says you know i sleep
like a baby
i'm awake every two hours you know and
that seems to be this highly polyphasic
mentality too
so that doesn't seem to be the case that
doesn't seem to be how
we should sleep and i would strongly
advise people not to do that
should we be sleeping though differently
than the way that we are
in modernity and i actually think there
is an argument for this
because if you look at hunter-gatherer
tribes whose way of life
hasn't changed for thousands of years
they don't sleep the way that we do they
don't sleep in what we call a monophasic
pattern which is trying to get one long
single bout at night and then we're
awake for 16 hours
they sleep by physically so typically
depending on what season be it winter
versus summer
they will sleep for anywhere between
sort of six to seven hours at night
and then they will have this siesta-like
behavior in the afternoon where they
have a nap
getting this sort of fuller opportunity
so i think modernity you could argue has
actually
dislocated us from how our natural edict
of sleep schedule
is there any other evidence to support
that there actually is
most people will know this somewhere
between about
two to four pm every day you will have a
drop
a pre-programmed and it's genetically
hardwired
drop in your alertness it's sort of you
know that um
you're around the boardroom table after
lunch
and all of a sudden you start starting
to see these head bobs
going on you know it's not people
listening to good music they're they're
just giving way to what we call the
postprandial dip in alertness
and it is decoupled on some level from
the food coma right like
part of it is oh i ate a big lunch but
this is independent of that you can
you can prevent people from having lunch
and they still have you know and i put
electrodes on their head we can still
measure this
alertness drop so it is independent of
food
right so siesta so siesta you know and
you can ask
well if that is how we were designed to
sleep
is there any evidence that something
goes wrong when you
change that natural behavior and
that actually happened as a natural well
an unfortunate natural experiment in
greece
a couple of decades ago they decided
that they were going to do away
with the siesta policy so if you went to
greece you know in the 1980s
and you walked around the towns you
would see on the shop windows it would
say
open from you know 10 to 2 p.m close
from 2 to
5 p.m and then open from 5 to 10 p.m
because there was a standardized siesta
practice
they decided to do away with that and so
harvard researchers
said okay we're going to see what
happens what are the consequences and
they focused on cardiovascular disease
so they tracked the sleep and the health
of cardiovascular health
of well over 23 000 greeks
and what they found is that across that
five-year period
there was a seven sorry there was a 37
percent
increased likelihood of having a heart
attack
in fact it was worse in males in males
there was a
60 increase in likelihood of having a
heart attack
and what was happening it seemed if you
looked at the data
is that they were still sleeping the
same maybe just
six hours a night and they were
doing away with the nap during the day
and they weren't replacing
that sleep time back into their night
phase they were staying
true to what they'd been doing before at
night and they'd just been shortchanged
of their sleep during the day
and that led to cardiovascular health
consequences wow
so if no siesta you got to make sure you
get the eight hours but if you're doing
if you if you're engaging in that hunter
gatherer or practice you can go
six and two or whatever and that seems
to be fine
i would say that there's probably a
couple of caveats with
naps though naps are a double-edged
sword um
if you are struggling with sleep at
night
the recommendation is do not nap during
the day
because what you want to do is build up
all of that healthy sleepiness and it's
a chemical called adenosine it's sleep
pressure essentially
and the longer that you've been awake
the more of that adenosine the more of
that
sleep pressure builds up and it's not a
mechanical pressure in your brain don't
worry it's a chemical pressure
to sleep and then after about 16 hours
of being awake there seems to be enough
adenosine enough
sort of sleepiness to be weighing down
on your shoulders
that now you can fall asleep and then
stay asleep so if you're someone who has
fragile sleep or insomnia
you shouldn't nap during the day because
taking a nap
during the day will actually just it's
almost like um
like a pressure valve on a steam cook-up
you just release some of that healthy
sleep pressure that's been building up
and now when it comes time to fall
asleep or stay asleep at night
it's that much harder so the advice
would be
if you can if you don't have sleep
problems and you can nap regularly
then i would say naps are just fine but
if you can't do it regularly
and especially if you suffer from sleep
problems try to stay away from naps
if you're going to nap nap before
2 p.m in the afternoon going later than
that can be problematic for your sleep
um you know it's a little bit like
snacking before your main meal
it just takes the edge off your appetite
it's the same way with naps
i'm sure you or somebody has studied
what happens if you
take exogenous adenosine right like
wouldn't that seem to be the way in to
resolving this problem for people that
that have insomnia hard to get it across
the brain barrier which is a protective
layer around the brain
and you know there's some issues around
toxicity as well so
um yeah that certainly would have been
the idea but what's
lovely is that you know you can increase
sort of
sleep pressure in a number of
non-pharmacological ways and exercise is
a great demonstration of that
and i think you know we can speak about
all of these different over-the-counter
medications that people try to invest in
and think that that's going to give them
a good night of sleep
but there are probably two really simple
things that you can do
non-medication that are if you look at
the data are almost guaranteed to
improve your sleep which is
some form of physical activity most days
or at least
several days a week and the second is
deal with your anxiety anxiety is the
principal cause of insomnia it's not the
only cause
but it's the our current working model
of insomnia
that people who have a high fight or
flight
activation of their nervous system um
branch of the nervous system
they also have high levels of stress
chemicals such as cortisol
and that seems to be very predictive of
their insomnia
and if you can start to manage your
anxiety
for example meditation is a fantastic
practice
and you know before i was writing the
book and i was um
sort of starting to research i was i was
a bit of a stupid hard-nosed scientist
you know i just thought this meditation
stuff was maybe a little bit woo-woo
and sort of you know come by our and we
all hold hands and
and i started to look at the data the
data was immensely powerful and very
robust that people
when they are suffering from insomnia if
you put them into a meditation a mindful
practice
you can actually drop the severity of
the
insomnia um in a way that medications
um such even prescription medications
can't come close to
mm-hmm yeah i mean i just know well
first of all if i don't exercise forget
about it
i'm gonna i know i'm gonna struggle with
sleep yeah me too at night
and if and when i have difficulty
falling asleep or i wake up in the
middle of the night
i've become very attuned to what my mind
is doing and it will generally default
to some problem that i'm having or
conflict that i'm trying to resolve and
i'll just loop some
narrative and that produces a tremendous
amount of anxiety
which obviously prevents me from falling
asleep so
i notice that and then i course correct
through either some kind of mindfulness
practice to kind of
create space and push that narrative
aside or or
you know overcome it with a different
narrative and sometimes i'll just
think about a book that i'm reading or a
movie that i saw
and i'll just immerse myself in that
narrative and
and that that's like a distraction
exactly literally
short circuits other anxiety-producing
narrative and i fall asleep
you're so right so i think you know in
this modern
day and age sort of you know the empty
fee
fast food 24 7 society we're constantly
on sort of reception particularly with
now all of this digital technology
and rarely do we do reflection
unfortunately the one time when we do
reflection is when a head hits the
pillow
and that's the last time that you want
to go into
rumination you know you don't want the
rolodex of anxiety
spinning up which is what you're sort of
you know describing because that leads
to something that we call
catastrophization that you start
thinking oh what didn't i do
today and what do i need to do more of
tomorrow and then i forgot this
and at that point you know good sleep is
not going to be
invited into the brain by the way
counting sheep does not work
um there was a scientific study done by
a colleague of mine at uc berkeley that
demonstrated
in fact if anything it it hurts your
sleep
and what if you're catastrophizing it
would probably be better to start
counting sheep it could be but what you
described was actually what she found
far better was to engage in some kind of
a mental aspect and what they found was
take yourself on a walk think about a
walk that you know in the forest or in
nature or down on the beach
and just start to try to walk yourself
through that or
think about you know a book that you're
reading or think about sort of a podcast
and
anything to get the mind off itself um
so for example i'm i feel embarrassed to
say this but um
i i love um racing cars and so if i'm
struggling with sleep which i off i do
too you know i am not immune to bad
nights of sleep and i've
had bad bouts of insomnia it's so
comforting to hear that
you know i'm just i'm just as fragile
and so what i'll do is you know i'll put
myself and i'll think about the track
and i'll
you know drive myself around the track i
know when i need to which gear i need to
be and where my
braking zones are and then the next
thing i know is i'm waking up in the
morning
and right just drifted off yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's great that's a
it's sort of a different version of what
i do
what kind of cars do you race uh oh gosh
i've raced all sorts um uh bmw's
porsches um but my my real love and the
the car that i
uh own um is a little mazda miata when
you're when you're a professor you can't
really
go racing in you know half million
dollar cars
and i i love it to pieces um it is
a car unlike you know ferrari or porsche
um when you're going uh 40 miles an hour
it feels like you're doing 100
whereas in a porsche when you're doing
100 it feels like 40 miles an hour
so i'm usually the slowest guy on track
but
um it brings me a lot of joy and
satisfaction that's cool
um well let's talk a little bit about
best practices then i feel like we're at
that
at that juncture and i want to do this
by walking you through
the extreme lengths that i've got i know
a little bit of your sleep history
so tend to include it yeah i sleep in
the tent
causes a lot of consternation and
confusion from people that
that uh listen to this show but i'll
just
provide a little background to that like
historically i've had
issues falling asleep part of it and i'm
interested in your take on this
is i think my sense is that it
germinates
somewhat from being like an extreme
ultra endurance athlete i've gone
through periods of my life where
i've put my body through just
unbelievable rigor like 25 hour training
weeks where you're just
so exhausted sleep is a non-issue sleep
is not a problem when you're pushing
yourself that hard
but it's been many years since i've been
kind of
habiting that space and now but i've but
i've acclimated my
my physical body is acclimated to to
doing that right so now
if i go out for a one-hour run or i go
on a casual bike ride
it's not enough like i'm not getting
enough of the
fatigue to create the restful state that
i aspire to be in like i really i have
to
exercise more than the average person
which is challenging when you're a busy
person so there's that
on top of that my body's like a furnace
like i literally burn hot and my wife
likes the bedroom a lot warmer than than
i do
and we would have these this back and
forth
over many years where you know it's too
cold for her it's too
i'm on top of all the cover she's
underneath them shivering it wasn't
working
and as kind of a joke i went and we have
a flat roof off of our bedroom and i
went and
i just you know pulled a twin mattress
up there and slept there one night i had
an unbelievable night of sleep
i thought this is fantastic it's nice
and cold out the desert air even in the
summer
and that i graduated from that into
getting a tent and i've been sleeping in
a tent ever since
i absolutely love it the cold air being
under the stars
and being under a bunch of blankets
including
a gravity blanket which i love your
thoughts on which i found to be
really helpful speaking about the
sympathetic nervous system and trying to
calm myself down
an eye mask and nature sounds and you
know
magnesium like all kinds of stuff and
the idea being of course to create the
optimal
situation for the best opportunity for
eight hours of sleep every night and and
like yourself i don't always
despite all of that sleep still eludes
me many nights
but on but more often than not i'm
getting more high quality sleep than i
used to
but i'm interested in how this kind of
measures up with what you found through
your studies about best practices
specifically
temperature you know air quality all
these kinds of things so
yeah and so i think there are probably
maybe five tips for you know better
sleep tonight
if you could suggest that or start
trying to optimize your sleep
um and temperature regularity
darkness um walk it out
and then alcohol and caffeine and i'll
save the last one because it usually
if you don't find me deeply unappealing
right now you will after that fifth one
temperature is a fascinating one we know
that your brain and your body need to
drop their core temperature by about one
degree celsius
or about two to three degrees fahrenheit
for you to fall asleep
and then stay asleep across the night
and that's the reason that you'll always
find it easier to fall asleep in a room
that's too
cold than too hot because too cold is
taking you in the right
thermal direction for good sleep and
that's why sleeping in a tent
you're you know now we understand we're
in southern california
but nevertheless you know it can get it
gets cooler at night than it is
during the day yeah i wouldn't be doing
this in boston right yeah it's still
i mean typically it's low 40s and it
goes down into the high 30s and i've
never
not slept in the tent because it was too
cold i know that in your research you
found there is an inflection point at
which point perhaps
you know too cold is not so good yeah
once you get into an extreme it
but i i have to tell you like you know
when it's 38 degrees i'm happy
yeah and i sleep pretty dang well yeah
and that i mean i got a lot of
i got a lot of blankets on yeah and so
it's sort of you know the local
temperature may not
quite be that my and here's the other
thing i always have my feet sticking out
i cannot have my feet under the covers
yeah do you know why
yeah i i think i know but yeah because
it's your hands and your feet
that are these incredible radiators of
heat
your hands and your feet are highly
vascular in other words there is this
crisscross
of vessels very close to the surface and
it's very rich in its vascular nature
both your hands and your feet and so at
night
what the body wants to do is almost like
a snake charmer
draw the heat out of the core of the
body
and evacuate it through the extremities
and the extremities in this case for us
human beings are hands and feet as well
as
head and that's why you will sometimes
see rebellious you know when you see
your kids and you kind of tuck them in
all nicely and
you know you look at your wife and your
smile and it's all beautiful and then
you go back in two hours later just
before you know you go to bed
and these rebellious legs are dangling
out you know sticking out
it's because you're trying to evacuate
the heat
so you're why's in doing that because
they are wonderful
thermal discharges um so that's
temperature and we do need to drop that
that temperature
it's different for different people but
i think the recommendation would
probably be about
you know 65 degrees or so for
most people now that's obviously
averaging across men and women and it's
different there too as you mentioned
which is around about if i do my math
correctly it's probably around about 18
18.3 degrees celsius
um so that's temperature and that's why
i think you
definitely will start to sleep better
than you at least would do otherwise
on a constant temperature because you
know there's another way that modernity
has dislocated us from our
natural edict of sleep which is we set
a thermostat of maybe 70 or 72 degrees
throughout the day in the night
and that's not how we were we're
sleeping now if you go back to those
hunter-gatherers by
the way for whom you are in some ways
mimicking their sleeping existence
they don't go to bed really on the basis
of light
which is what we thought they usually
will go to bed about an hour and a half
to two hours after
sundown and then when they wake up and
they don't have alarms
if you ask them about this idea of you
know artificially terminating sleep with
an alarm
that perplexed also you know rates of
insomnia in the general first world
population is somewhere between ten to
fifteen percent
in those hunter-gatherer tribes it's
less than five percent
so some things are also moving all day
long they're moving all day long
and you know we can look at diet as well
but so
what is determining their sleep onset
and their sleep
offset it's not light it's temperature
so when the and if you ask people if you
just bring them into the laboratory and
you say
um you know at what point do you feel
sleepy at night
it's at the point where their core body
temperature is on
the steepest decline now they don't know
that
even though unfortunately we've placed a
rectal probe inside of them which
is no fun for either the experimenter to
insert or for the participant to receive
but they are on the awesome downslope of
their
thermal evacuation and that's when they
feel sleepy
and when those hunter-gatherer tribes
wish to wake up
is before dawn just before dawn but it's
as the temperature starts to rise back
up
so it turns out that we actually need to
warm up a little bit
to get cold we need to bring the blood
to the surface of the skin that's why
cold it must be in the bedroom but you
can wear socks if you want or you can
have a hot water bottle
but keep it cold because warming the
feet or sticking them out of the you
know
the mattress will help your body
evacuate the heat and
plummet your core body temperature and
it's the reason by the way that hot
baths and showers work for good sleep as
well
no you think in a counter-intuitive way
right because you think you're warming
up
you're nice and toasty yeah your vas are
dilating
when you get out the bath you've got
rosy cheeks all of the blood comes to
the surface
and when you get out of the bath your
core body temperature
is dropping precipitously that's why you
fall asleep
it's called the warm bath effect in
sleep science it's so reliable
um and then when they're starting to
wake up is when they're starting to warm
up
so we need to sort of you know warm up
to get cold to get to sleep then we need
to stay cold to stay asleep
and then we need to warm up to wake up
right if that's the sort of temperature
transition so that's
temperature um the next is
regularity go to bed at the same time
and wake up at the same time
no matter whether it's the weekday or
the weekend or even if you've had a bad
night of sleep
don't change it resist the urge my
recommendation to people who've
you know had a bad night of insomnia
they'll say should i get to bed earlier
should i wake up later do nothing
don't go to bed any earlier don't try to
wake up any later
keep to your schedule and by the way i'm
giving these sort of
you know these tips or these rules
people don't
respond to rules people respond to
reasons not rules and that's why i'm
if you don't mind him he's a diplomat
trying to give some explanation
uh as to underlying it but the reason
that regularity
is king is because it will anchor your
sleep and it will improve the quantity
and the quality of that sleep
because deep within your brain there is
a master 24-hour clock
and it expects regularity and thrives
best
under conditions of regularity including
the regulation of your sleep wake
schedule
sorry i i just want to interrupt with
one thing which is
on that subject of the the internal
clock
does it matter in the context of getting
eight hours if you
choose to go to bed at nine o'clock or
you go to bed at 11 o'clock if you're
getting eight hours
is that going to impact the quality of
your sleep like i know personally like i
need to go to bed early
yeah if i if i still get eight hours but
i go to bed late it's not the same thing
yeah and so we mentioned that you know
overall for the average adult
you know you get most of your deep sleep
in the first half of the night
most of your rem sleep in the second
half of the night but it's not quite
that simple and by the way you know some
people will say to me
isn't the sleep that you get before
midnight twice as valuable as that
that you get after midnight you know and
there's nothing you know
the stroke of midnight you know there's
nothing about the sleep that you were
getting at 11
59 you know p.m and the sleep that
you're getting at 1201
am and that's a fallacy but what you
described is
important and it's a nuance and it comes
back to what we call
chronotype are you a morning type
evening type or somewhere in between
and it's about a third split across the
population
you don't get to decide it's not if
you're a night owl
it's not your fault it's gifted by way
largely of your genetics
it was gifted to you at birth and it is
hard-wired and we now know the genes
at least six different genes determine
whether you're
a morning lock or an evening owl or
sitting somewhere in between
but it's interesting to know that that's
a genetic disposition you can't compel a
night owl to be a morning person no
people have done all sorts of incredible
things and there is
some degree of wiggle room uh you can do
i think there's about
five or six different things that they
tried but all you can really do is drag
a night owl back by maybe 30 minutes
and that's really it so what you're
describing there in terms of the quality
of your sleep is important because
it's less about where any adult places
that eight hours on the 24-hour clock
face
it's more about where that individual
adult
is trying to sleep in harmony with their
chronotype
rather than against their chronotype now
unfortunately
modernity is you know is predisposed to
a heavy bias and a discrimination
towards morning types
you know it's the type a culture that
rise and grind you get up in the morning
and it's all about the early bird
catches the worm
well i can also tell you that you know
the second mouse gets the cheese
you know so you need to be really
mindful of your chronotype now
you can figure out your chronotype if
you want you can just go online
and you can uh what's the best probably
search something called
morningness eveningness questionnaire
and i can send you a link that we can
even put in the show notes
um the meq and it's a series of
questions
um and you will determine what type you
are trying to then sleep at the right
timing in accordance in harmony rather
than
in desynchrony with your chronotype is
when you will get the best
quality of sleep that's why you say if i
go to bed at midnight and i sleep
in it till eight sometimes i kind of
have a sleep hangover i just feel
miserable
but if i get to bed at whatever time you
normally do earlier in the evening and
wake up earlier
that's my sweet spot right most people
probably know
what their type is they do right well i
i think yes and no because
you know in some ways even the middle
ground
folks will think that they
are you know perhaps more evening type
than they actually are because of
technology
you know we've we've done a lot of work
in the sleep field we
the royal we um by the way in this
podcast when i've said
we did something i mean that sort of uh
or when i say
i know i did something i mean we did
something and when i say we did
something i mean they did something
but um so we've done a lot of work
looking at technology
and the invasion of technology into our
lives and into our evenings and into the
bedroom
and certainly those blue light devices
um
are damaging to the release of melatonin
which we'll we'll come on to when we
speak about darkness
but it's not really that which now seems
to be
carrying the vote of technology-based
sleep disruption
it's that these things are activating
they are designed to capture your
attention
and make you more alert and in fact it's
what
ends up happening is that you have sleep
procrastination
where you're using these devices you're
working on your laptop
and you think i'm not sleepy i don't
feel tired but if there were to be some
electromagnetic pulse that wiped out all
of technology
you know what you would realize is that
at 10 30 all the lights went out you
couldn't do anything
within five or ten minutes you think wow
gosh actually you know what i
i really am sleepy and technology
will mask your sleepiness that
activating nature of technology hits the
mute button on your sleepiness
so you don't perceive it right in a in a
multifaceted way right there's the
dopamine
induction of social media scrolling but
there's also
the light spectrum and all of that right
that's right
you know impacting your body's ability
to properly self-regulate
yeah yeah and so you know i often if you
really have to take your phone into your
bedroom i don't uh personally but again
you know that's just me i would say the
one rule i would offer to you
is that if you're going to be using your
phone in the bedroom
you have to be standing up you know and
at that point after about five or six
minutes
today you're like you know what i just
want to if you sit down on the bed
i'm sorry phone goes away here's what's
depressing though and you talk about
this like what it went how
like how long before you need to go to
bed should you shut the screen off and
it was like a number of hours right like
if you watch a movie
and then go to bed uh that movie
should be concluded like i don't know
what did you say like two hours
well it really depends on sort of you
know watching television or a movie
um as long as it's not inside of the
bedroom we really
shouldn't be watching television inside
of the bedroom because you want to
associate your bed
with simply the place of being asleep or
for intimacy that's really what we
recommend the bed for
don't be working on there don't be
eating on your bed don't be watching
television on your bed consuming netflix
and i think it's really about computers
and you know ipads and cell phones or
laptops uh
sorry um tablets um i think watching
television outside of the bedroom
uh is okay one of the dangers however
when i ask people you know if they say
i'm having sleep problems i'll say you
know do you nap during the day and
they'll say no i never nap
then i'll say well but when you're
watching television uh on the couch in
the evening do you sometimes fall asleep
watching television they say yeah i do
that all the time
that's an accidental nap and it's the
worst
time to nap too because again it's right
before your main meal of sleep
so i would say that if you're doing
something that helps you wind down and
just disengage from the day
disengage from those stresses that's
fine be it reading a book
watching a mindless movie but in the
last hour before bed stay away from
anything that you know is cognitively
and
especially emotionally activating don't
be checking emails
don't be sending texts um you know don't
be
engaging in movies that are you know
action horror movies that have you
wired right try to stay away from those
things right
yeah um so let's talk about uh
caffeine and alcohol right so
disappointingly caffeine has like an
eight-hour half-life right so if you
have a cup of coffee in the morning
yeah you're still contending with it
when you go to bed it's tough yeah so
um alcohol and caffeine so everyone
knows that caffeine is an alerting
substance
um it's in a class of drugs that we call
the psychoactive stimulants
interesting it's one of the only
psychoactive stimulants that we readily
give to
children without too much concern so
you know many people know that that's
how caffeine
works but people may not realize that
caffeine can have
two additional damaging effects on your
sleep
the first comes down to as you said the
duration of action
that caffeine has for most people a
half-life of what we call about five to
six hours in other words
after about five to six hours fifty
percent of that caffeine is still in
your system
which means that caffeine has a quarter
life of between 10 to 12 hours
so if you have a cup of coffee at let's
say 2 pm
a quarter of that caffeine could still
be circulating your brain at midnight
so it would be the equivalent of you
know a 2pm
cup of coffee is the equivalent of
getting into bed and just before you
turn out the light
you swig a quarter of a cup of starbucks
and you hope for a good night of sleep
it's it's probably not going to happen
right now yeah
there are there are differences from one
individual to the next it comes down to
the specific
enzyme that degrades caffeine some
people have
a genetic variant what we call a
polymorphism that
um has a faster metabolic rate
for the degradation of caffeine other
people have slow that
usually determines i'm a sensitive
person i'm not sensitive
but even if you're one of those people
and some people say this to me look
i can have an espresso with dinner and i
fall asleep fine and i stay asleep so
no problem that's not quite true because
even if you fall asleep and stay asleep
caffeine can actually decrease the
amount of deep non-rem sleep that you
get
can decrease the quality of that deep
sleep by up to 20
wow now for me to drop your deep sleep
quality
i would have to age you by a decade
or you could do it with a cup of coffee
in the evening
you know each and every night and the
problem is that then
those people when they wake up the next
morning they don't remember struggling
to fall asleep
they don't remember waking up frequently
throughout the night so they don't put
two and two
together but now they feel unrefreshed
and unrestored by their sleep because
they weren't getting the deep sleep
and now they find themselves reaching
for more caffeine three cups of coffee
in the morning
and then because they may not be able to
get to sleep at night then they're
reaching for sleeping pills
so it's this sort of you know it's the
stimulant in the morning
it's a sedative in the evening and it's
a very difficult cycle to break
um so that's caffeine uh
alcohol um alcohol is probably the most
misunderstood sleep aid that there is
out there it's anything but a sleep aid
and
you know you've mentioned how your sleep
was so disrupted
um firstly alcohol isn't a class of
drugs that we call
the sedatives and sedation is not sleep
but when we have a couple of drinks in
the evening and we say gosh i just fell
asleep like that
you're mistaking sedation for sleep so
if i were to show you your electrical
patterns of brainwave activity with and
without alcohol
they're not the same it's not
naturalistic brain brainwave activity
the second problem with alcohol is that
it fragments your sleep
so that you wake up many more times
throughout the night
so not only is your sleep um you know
going to be poor quality as we'll come
on to
it's also just not going to be
consolidated it's not that nice
long duration of uninterrupted sleep
because as your body
is processing the alcohol the the
depressant
aspect of that drug is wearing off and
there's a there's a sort of rubber
banding stick
to it right so you wake up at two or
three in the morning yep so it actually
will start to just as you mentioned
there
it will trigger activation of the fight
or flight branch so you start to come
back online in terms of that
stress-related branch of the nervous
system uh also stress-related
neurochemicals we know
are starting to get increased as the
alcohol is metabolized
and that's what causes the fragmentation
of your sleep the final problem with
alcohol
is that it's a very potent suppressor of
your rem sleep of your dream sleep
which we've mentioned before in terms of
all of its benefits
um and so you know i think that's the
the reason that alcohol should just be
strongly advised against you know
against the the nightcap
um by medical practitioners
but i would just say two things firstly
with tongue and cheek
you know you could look at that data and
say well then i should just go to the
pub in the morning and that way the
alcohol is out of my system in the
evening and now
but yeah problem with me is if i go to
the pub in the morning i'm at the pub at
night too
and so i would never say that as a
healthcare professional um
but what about like just a glass like
hey i'm having a glass of wine at dinner
yeah i would love to say that you know
based on the data that doesn't have an
impact but if you look at the data even
uh
even the glass can have a measurable
impact
um but look i the other thing i want to
note is this and i think it's something
that i've learned in
after the book was published and i'm
embarrassed
in the way i was acting before um
i don't want to be puritanical here rich
you know i don't
i don't want to tell people how to live
their lives i'm just a scientist
all i want to try and do and i may be
too enthusiastic in doing this
is gift people with the science and the
knowledge of sleep
and then they can make an empowered
choice as to how they want to live their
life
if they're trying to optimize their
sleep um so i do want to mention that i
i'm not finger wagging and
i shouldn't be telling anyone how to
matt i don't think anyone's getting that
impression
i don't know i think it's it's like look
this is what's going on like make your
own you know
choose accordingly right but just so
everybody knows like let's be clear
about
what the science says in terms of how
this impacts you yeah but i think i've
been sometimes
overstepped the mark so it's good you're
such a gentle guy
but i also should say like i love how
enthusiastic because you talk about this
stuff a lot but
you're so enthusiastic your whole body
like lights up oh gosh
i fell in love with you know i fell for
sleep like a blind roof you know
it was just the most amazing thing as i
was starting to study it
and it is a love of fur that has lasted
me 20
years and i am still beguiled by this
beautiful thing called sleep at night
yeah there's so much more still to be
learned right like
yeah you know i mean it's you know i
think it's remains one of the last great
scientific mysteries i would say though
and the reason that
you're a you know someone like me is
able to write a book um that's over 130
000 words is because
you know we've learned more in the
previous 50 years about sleep than we
did in the previous 5 thousand
and even just 30 or 40 years ago we used
to ask the question
you know what is sleep good for and the
crass answer was that well
we sleep to cure sleepiness which is the
fatuous equivalent
of saying we eat to cure hunger that
tells you nothing about
you know the nutritional physiological
metabolic benefits of
food now 30 or 40 years later
we've had to upend that question we've
had to ask
is there any major organ system in your
body
or is there any operation of the mind
that isn't
wonderfully enhanced when we get sleep
or demonstrably impaired when we don't
get enough
and the answer seems to be no right i
have to ask you this
every full moon i don't sleep and i
don't know if it's psychosomatic or
there's some kind of
lunar gravitational pull occurring but
have you looked at this
we have have you yeah please do tell
there's some conflicting evidence so
some reports have found this effect
other reports have not and it
may be different for men and women even
some of the reports are saying
on average people sleep less
with the full moon so have you ever
thought about the term
or what the term means lunatic
and it occurred to me when i was doing
that work
based on the relationship between sleep
and your emotional health that you
essentially your emotional integrity
falls apart when you're not getting
sufficient sleep you know you become
emotionally
unhinged you become pendulum-like in
your emotional irrationality
it occurred to me i wonder if part of
the derivative of that term
you know we've got all these things you
know the werewolf people getting crazy
right yeah yeah like when the moon's out
people lose their minds
right and you know i think some of that
is due to you know different practices
around the celebration of the moon
phases et cetera
but you know i think if you see believe
some of the reports but again some of
the reports have failed to find this
effect
um sleep duration decreases why would
that be
there are some theories around that
which actually i should finish up my
tips
and there's just two more of them but
this is nice because it brings us back
to this
with a full moon obviously as long as
it's not a cloudy night you get more
luminance
right and that light of that luminance
can actually
decrease the hormone of melatonin
and this comes back to what were i think
the the
fourth out of the five tips which is
darkness we are a dark deprived society
in this modern era
and we need darkness at night to trigger
the release of this hormone called
melatonin
and melatonin is often called sort of
the vampire hormone
not because it makes you want to look
longingly at people's necklines and
you know bite in it's because it comes
out at night it's the the hormone of
darkness
and melatonin helps time the healthy
onset
of sleep and so the recommendation would
be in the last hour before bed
don't just stay away from those blue
light emitting devices
try dimming down half of the lights in
your house
you would actually be surprised at how
sleepy and soperific
that change can be and that's why i love
the idea of sleeping in a tent
because all of a sudden you know you are
removed from
all of that you know polluting electric
light
even at night now we should reverse
engineer that trick during the day
in the first half of the day it's
critical to get some exposure
to daylight you can go outside but it
doesn't
mean that you have to go outside just
being next to a window
try to get at least 40 minutes of direct
sunlight
each and every morning and that will
really help because that will then stamp
the brakes on melatonin
it will shut it down and you will feel
more alert
the more alert you feel the more healthy
sleepiness the more of that adenosine
which is the sleep pressure chemical
that you will build up
and then the better your sleep will be
at night right
so that's sort of darkness and and i
think that's perhaps
part of the explanation why the full
moon can maybe disrupt our sleep because
it's nowhere near like sunlight but it's
still a light invasion
the eye mask in the whole thing i think
there's something more mysterious
at play i don't know but maybe i'll try
taking melatonin i know that you've said
you know taking melatonin as a matter of
course is not a good idea it's really
for when you're
traveling across time zones yeah but
maybe
maybe i'll try it when the next full
moon cycle comes
yeah i mean melatonin um as i mentioned
it regulates the timing of your sleep
but it doesn't actually really help in
the generation of sleep
if you look at people who are not jet
lagged and
who are under the age of 50. melatonin
in all of the placebo-controlled cities
that we found
doesn't really change the quantity or
the quality of your sleep
melatonin you can think of it a little
bit like the starting official at the
100 meter race
you know melatonin is the thing that
will gather all of the
the races to the start and then begin
the great sleep race
but melatonin doesn't participate in the
race itself that's a whole different set
of brain chemicals
[Music]
but i would say two things regarding
melatonin
first if you think that it's working for
you
then the placebo effect is the most
reliable effect in all of pharmacology
with the exception of probably an
adrenaline injection to your heart
so no harm no foul there the caveat that
i would like to add to that
secondarily is it's over the counter at
least here in the united states which
means it's not regulated by the fda
and in a study that looked at over 20
different
brands of melatonin what they found is
that based on what it said on the bottle
relative to what was actually in those
melatonin pills
it was anywhere between eighty percent
less
up to four hundred and sixty percent
more than what it said on the bottle
so it's a wild west you don't really
know what is there a trusted brand
well i think you know firstly i should
also mention that melatonin is is still
largely a safe
compound you know even in high doses you
know it's it's
its concern from that aspect is perhaps
perhaps lower
but because it's unregulated what one of
the things i've been seeing right now
you know are melatonin gummies for kids
and you know maybe we'll learn more
about melatonin and it could help
kids with sleep problems or sleep
disorders but
if it's unregulated you know you don't
know what
you're giving wouldn't the concern also
be if you're if you're taking it all the
time doesn't that signal your body to
stop producing it
that's right so that's the other major
sort of issue is that
most people are taking too much
melatonin they're taking usually between
five milligrams up to ten milligrams
i would recommend based on the science
somewhere between just point five to
three milligrams
because if you're dosing any higher your
body has this beautiful network of
feedback loops
and it starts to think well my goodness
you know
i don't need to produce melatonin
because i'm i'm getting it every night
in very high dose
i can just shut down my own melatonin
production so that's the danger just be
a little bit mindful
on that on the subject of light you know
talking about the the
the light on a full moon um i've come to
develop a greater appreciation for the
brain's capacity to
um process spectrum spectrums of light
and and how that relates to how we
calibrate our internal clock like i've
had i had
um neuroscientist andrew huberman here
do you know oh yes from stanford yeah
right right
actually we've never met you guys we
know of each other
and we should at some point we should
get together and
because i think we'd have a lovely time
together yeah yeah he's doing some
interesting work but he talks a lot
about how
really the eye is you know is is the
brain
right like the optic nerve is part of
the brain and
the sensitivity of the optic nerve to
all these variations in
in light spectrum he talks about looking
at you know at how looking at a sunset
you know
kind of helps calibrate all of that all
of these different things
and i was thinking about that the other
day because i play this game when i wake
up with myself when i wake up in the
morning
i open up my eyes i don't have an alarm
clock
and i try to guess exactly what time it
is
and it's pretty amazing like i'm
generally i don't always get it right
but i'm generally like within
two minutes of of the precise time
and i thought is that because my eye
knows the
specific light spectrum of what time of
day it is or is it my internal clock
like what is what is that but there is
this deep knowing i think that we have
when we are more in nature where we're
attuned to these rhythms i think it's a
combination of both
um and um by the way his work is just
fantastic if
if people i know you've had him on your
show just this he is just a brilliant
scientist and a
he's so eloquent and beautiful he's a
very effective communicator
he knows how to explain things in a way
where people can really understand what
he's talking about yeah
he's wonderful but so i think it's a
combination of those two things
you know i think many of us even if
we've got blackout curtains and sort of
you know we're wearing an eye mask we
will
wake up and i think we have some general
sense but maybe plus or minus an
hour in terms of accuracy that okay it's
still probably the middle of the night
or it kind of feels like late in the
morning
and in part that's because you do have
an internal 24-hour clock
but i also think that there's something
that we've lost
in terms of our light exposure that you
have gained back which is that it's not
just that your internal clock which
may get you you know within one hour
plus or minus
it it's not bad at doing that but when
you open up your
eyes and you get additional exogenous
information which is from the outside
world rather than the endogenous
clock time that your 24 o'clock is
giving you
then you shift from plus or minus an
hour of accuracy
to maybe plus off minus five minutes you
know
and so fascinating you know i i love
this you know it's something i i
um when i retire maybe i'll look at this
because there's something very strange
about
sleep and time that is utterly
paradoxical
and what i mean by this is you can say
okay i've got to wake up
cause i'm going to um you know i'm going
to fly out and meet matt walker in
berkeley and
you know we're going to grab coffee and
i've got to get this early morning
flight from lax
and you set your alarm for you know five
o'clock in the morning
and guaranteed you will wake up at 4 50.
100 percent how is that right possible
it happens too frequently for it to be
you know just by chance so somewhere
your brain has this quartz-like
precision of
clock counting however there is an
absence of time particularly in dreaming
because all of us have probably had that
experience that our alarm goes off
and we were in this strange dream and
then we hit the snooze button and our
snooze button is just two minutes
and we go back and we go right back into
the dream again
and then the snooze button goes off and
you think
now hang on a second i was that felt
like almost
an hour of an experience
so there is this temporal mismatch
where when we go into the dream state we
can almost fold and compress
time like a concertina it's like
inception yeah and i think it's no big
surprise that nolan
picked up on that you know with the help
of maybe some you know sleep um
specialists uh offering that advice we
know that
you get this you know this dilation i've
called it sort of
dream dilation or dream time dilation
where time is right like so what do you
what do you make of that like what would
be
the evolutionary advantage of that
well it may be that there is no
necessarily evolutionary advantage but
there may be a brain mechanism that
explains it
because what we know is that memories
are replayed
during both deep sleep and rem sleep now
when we are in deep sleep memories are
actually
sped up the brain will actually be
replaying those memories anywhere
between five to twenty times
faster but when we go into dream sleep
the replay is actually much slower
and so that may be why you know if you
if you want to speak about um
that's that's usually the one question i
i i i look forward to lisa
when i give talks someone put the hand
up and say is inception possible
and my heart just sinks i start seeing a
spinning top and the music that comes by
but you know i think that that's why
nolan had that beautiful idea that when
you descend
down into these different levels of
sleep
you know a minute of time in the real
world
could be you know five minutes of time
in the dream world and then if he gets
you to deeper dream states you know
then you know a minute of time in the
real world is
two hours or two days or 50 years well
with the premise being i'm going to
anchor
this memory or this concept or this idea
in this human's brain and the way to do
that
how do you do that in an effective way
where it's going to stay
right and when you when you think about
this in the context of
of you know morphing time constructs if
you have
a dream state in which memories are
accelerated that's certainly going to
aid in
the development of skill acquisition
right like you're repeating a memory or
a behavior or
just imagine you know you're in jiu
jitsu and you learned a new maneuver or
whatever and you're replaying that in
your mind of course
that's going to anchor that and then the
slowing down is almost like a
visualization
well but both of those things would work
in tandem
to really you know sort of calcify
neural pathways
around like a new concept oh you didn't
defeat it
you need to be a scientist rich would
you
direct my sleep sensitivity my mom would
be very happy
back to medical school no you're too
precious in what you do otherwise
um but so you're absolutely right that i
think what we know is that
deep sleep will one of its functions is
that
it will hit the save button on your
memories so that you don't forget
so deep sleep will future proof that
information within the brain
and in part it's just as you said it's
deep sleep that's basically scoring the
memory trace almost
etching it you know into
the the glass of the brain but
then you know dream sleep comes along
and what we've realized is that dream
sleep does something very different for
memories
sleep is much more intelligent than we
ever gave it credit when it comes to
information processing
sleep not only strengthens individual
memories
it will intelligently stitch and
associate those new memories together
and it seems to be during sleep
particularly during dream sleep
when we perform it's almost like
informational alchemy
um or it's like group therapy for
memories maybe that's a better analogy
you know that um sleep gathers in all of
this information that you've been
learning during the day and everyone
gets a name badge
but sleep forces you to go and speak to
the people not at the front of the room
that you think i've got the most obvious
connection with
it forces you to speak to the people at
the back of the room that you think
you've got no connection with at all
now it turns out that you do and it's a
non-obvious connection
but it's a potentially powerful one
nonetheless
because when you start to fuse things
together that shouldn't normally go
together
but offer marked advances in
evolutionary fitness
it sounds like the biological basis of
creativity
and that's where we see dream sleep
providing a benefit
you wake up the next day with a revised
mind
wide web of associations and you are
capable
of defining solutions to previously
impenetrable problems
it's the reason that you've never been
told to stay awake on a problem
right sleep on a problem but it's a it
has a very
strange and elusive relationship with
memory like memory doesn't seem to
really
be required for this right like
sometimes you will the recollection
you remember some of this stuff and then
it fades but
nonetheless the brain is doing its job
in that state and you're able to come up
with a creative solution or solve a
problem that
mystified you the night before yeah and
i have another
it's probably second only to the idiocy
of my idea that we
never evolved sleep that we we we have
you know it was from sleep that
wakefulness emerged that we started
at the top of the the podcast the other
stupid theory
is that in fact we remember all of our
dreams
you know most of us when we wake up we
if we can remember a dream it's it's
usually very difficult
and different people have different
dream recall strengths um
and the harder that we try you know the
right
unlike the more unlikely it is but
i think that that's not a problem of
memory imprinting
i think that's the difference in memory
science that we call
accessibility versus availability
i think one when we wake up in the
morning we
lose the ip address to the memory so we
can't find it
so it's availability is prevented
but i believe it's accessibility it's
it's still
present there we just can't so sort of
sorry
it's i got that wrong encrypted it's
evade its availability is still there
but it's accessibility
is prevented and the reason i i think
this is a tenable theory and i've got
some
ideas as how to test it is because you
can wake up in the morning think oh i
was having this incredible dream and
and and you just can't bring it back to
mind and you think okay
it's just gone and then two or three
days later
you're walking down the street and you
see a sign or you're in the shower and
you see the shampoo bottle
and all of a sudden there's a cue that
triggers the unleashing of that dream
memory and it all comes flooding back
in other words that memory was there all
along
you just didn't have accessibility to a
still yet
available and present memory now if
that's true
what it could mean is that we store
all of our dreams and the reason i find
that
sort of hand waving wacky and fun
philosophically to think about
is we know that memory
operates largely in a non-conscious
manner
you know you can for example if you're
walking up a set of stairs and you you
know
you've got your pad of paper and you've
left a drink on the stairs
you know you sort of you're reaching
down to pick it up that's an immensely
complex challenge you had to
sort of compute the physics of where
your hand was you had to know what the
weight of that cup was this is all based
on memory
and it operates way below the radar of
consciousness
most memories do if that's true
that our behavior is certainly
influenced non-consciously by our
memories it's what we call
implicit memory and we remember many of
our dreams
then all of a sudden it becomes
interesting to ask
how much does our waking life
um reflect or is shaped by
our stored dreams in an unconscious way
in an unconscious
way now this is getting very freudian
and i i have to say i'm not a big
advocate of freud i think he
um you know he did a remarkable service
to
the science of sleep he brought dreams
into the world of the mind before it was
you know in the greeks it was coming
from gods
you know hypnos sumness you know um
morpheus
and then chinese cultures had an idea
that dreams came from the soul
but it was freud who actually placed
dreaming squirrelly
within the mind in other words freud
made dream science
a domain of brain science of
neuroscience
now after that it all kind of went south
you know and i often joke that
i think freud was 50 right and 100 wrong
and so and it's not when it got into
their interpretation
exactly and that's just and we've
demonstrated that it's why it's no
longer embraced by the scientific
community as a scientific hypothesis
because it's untestable it has no solid
predictions
um and i think it's good to keep in mind
that you know there are some reports
that at the time freud was doing enough
cocaine to kill a small horse when he
was coming up with some of that too
so maybe you wanted to cocaine yeah i
know what is it about me
i can't seem to get away from it so um
so i think
i i have this enamored theory about
um dreaming and it's just not very
fundable so it's hard to get the uh
the funds i mean i think it's
the ultimate you know unknown terrain
and all in
and just unbelievably fascinating like
the idea that our our brain is so
complex and it's
it's it's performing this
mystical dance and computation while we
sleep
and the extent to which we barely begin
to understand what that's all about i
think is just
super interesting i mean you mentioned
this you know very early on in in our
taping about dreams
it is another very strange state you
know because
last night you and i both became
flagrantly psychotic
and we did that multiple times
throughout the night
now before you dismiss my kind of you
know diagnosis of our nighttime
psychosis i'll give you five good
reasons
firstly when we went into dream sleep we
started to see things which were not
there so we're hallucinating
second we believe things that couldn't
possibly be true
so we're delusional third we get
confused about time
place and person so we're suffering from
disorientation
fourth we have wildly fluctuating
emotions something that psychiatrists
call being
affectively labile and then how
wonderful you and i woke up this morning
and we forgot most if not all of that
dream experience we were paralyzed from
amnesia we were paralyzed throughout
many people don't realize this that when
you go into
dream sleep your brain paralyzes your
body
so the mind can dream safely so you
don't act out your dreams
and there is the the parts of the brain
that actually control the different
stages of sleep
uh in part are deep down within the
brain stem now
when the brain is ratcheting up its
upstairs
activation of the brain for rem sleep
for dreaming
it sends another signal down along the
spinal cord
and it paralyzes what are called the
alpha motor neurons in your spinal cord
these control all of your voluntary
skeletal muscles so
when you deliberately want to move your
hand move your foot sort of change your
mouth speak etc
so you are locked in physical
incarceration
during rem sleep you are imprisoned
within your own body
so when you have that or i should say
when i've had these experiences where
i'm being chased or something's
happening and i feel like i'm
stuck in molasses or i want to scream
and i'm like my wife
julie will like the next morning she'll
be like you are making the weirdest
noises
and i'll have some memory that will
trigger a memory like oh i was being
i was being pursued and i was trying to
get away and i i couldn't you know and i
was
and i was screaming out for help but i
couldn't even make a noise
that's exactly why you see he's too much
of a good scientist
what is so is sleepwalking then
um a malfunction and that
paralytic system like what's happening
when you're sleepwalking
no so sleep walking sleep talking um
there are group of disorders
called parasomnias which sort of
essentially means just
disorders that happen around sleep
parameaning around
sleep walking and sleep talking actually
don't come from rem sleep you would
imagine that they do and it's a very
logical thing
in fact what happens is that when we are
in deep sleep
for reasons that we don't quite yet
understand but it may be that there's a
jolt of nervous system activity and all
of a sudden your brain
races or it tries to race from the
basement of deep sleep
all the way up to the penthouse of
wakefulness but it gets stuck somewhere
in between
like the 13th floor for example and
what's strange and
we can do this in the sleep laboratory
where we've got these electrodes
and what we're seeing outside in terms
of the brain waves is deep sleep
but when you look at the camera all of a
sudden the patient is out the bed
and the sort of you know they're sort of
moving around and
so if you wake someone up who's having a
sleep walking or sleep talking event
and you say you know what was going
through your mind
they will they usually won't tell you
anything right and the reason is because
they're in deep sleep they're not in
dreams
so interesting um yeah i have some epic
sleepwalking stories from when i was a
kid yeah i went out i i got up in the
middle of the night
and and went outside in the middle of a
thunderstorm and like walked
a block away from the house until my dad
discovered what i and i woke up standing
in the middle of the street
in a downpour there are some remarkable
case
studies you know some of which i
discussed in the book um
where people have these episodes and
some you know
some dangerous and some unfortunate
things really happen but then i just
grew out of it like how
normal is that it's very normal so the
incidence
of of sleep walking and sleep talking
is far higher when we're kids
and most adults will grow out of it not
all adults
but most adults will grow out of it and
it's not really
a sleep disorder necessarily i think
you know and again i'm not you know i'm
not a clinician so and i'm not trying to
pretend to be a
sort of a doctor in any means but i
think the general advice is
if it's not causing you distress and
it's not putting you
in harm's way then one may not need to
worry about it if it's sort of
infrequent but if it is causing you to
stress and it is putting you in harm's
way
then you can go see your your doctor um
and i should note by the way something
too on those sort of five tips
and i should mention walk it out um just
which is the last one
you know none of those tips are really
going to help
anyone who has insomnia or
you know sleep apnea it's like me being
you know
your performance coach i can give you
all sorts of tips to optimize your
performance
but if you've got a broken ankle none of
those tips are going to help you we've
got to get you to a doctor
treat the broken ankle and then we come
back to sort of optimizing your sleep so
the tips i'm giving are just that right
i understand but what percentage of
people are truly insomniacs versus
people who have habits that prevent them
from getting a good night's sleep and
call themselves insomniacs
it's it's actually very difficult to
tell because part of the treatment for
insomnia which is now
no longer sleeping pills the first line
treatment has to be something called
cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia or cbti
for short um one of the things that
works towards
um so as you can tell by the name
cognitive behavioral
there is an aspect where we work on the
mind and we work around
you know your beliefs and your
expectations and your understanding of
sleep that's the cognitive
part of cbti the behavioral part
is actually asking what behaviors are
you engaging in
that are harming your sleep and what
things are you not doing behaviorally
that can help your sleep alcohol
caffeine regularity
light etc so those do play a role
but usually it's much more of a
combination of different things with
cbti it's much more extensive than that
it's just as effective for sleeping
pills in the short term
much more effective in the long term
unlike sleeping pills when you stop
working with your therapist
the benefits of cbti cognitive
behavioral therapy for insomnia
last for up to five years but for
sleeping pills when you stop using them
not
only do you typically go back to the bad
sleep you are having
you actually have even worse sleep it's
called rebound insomnia caused by these
sleep medications
yeah i have i have friends who are in
recovery for for
ambien and the stories they tell are
just harrowing
yeah yeah it's and you know there is a
time and a place for those medications
they're usually recommended for
acute short-term significant episodes so
let's say that you're already struggling
with
a trauma or bereavement or something
along those lines then
in combination with therapy they can be
advised for short-term use the problem
is most people aren't using them in a
short-term use model
you know and i i the reason in part i
know this is
um i think it took george lucas about 30
or 40 years to amass something like 2
billion
in uh profit from the star wars
franchise
it took ambien less than 24 months to do
that
so you can't do that with acute use um
so i again i sleeping pills have been
associated with
a high risk of death as well as cancer
do we know that that's causal or not no
we don't right now and i can make an
argument as to why it may not be causal
but i can also make a scientific
argument as to why it is
causal we probably won't ever find out
because based on the association between
mortality risk and things such as cancer
and sleeping pill use it's probably
going to be unethical to do a study
where you put people healthy people on
sleeping pills for
several years because of the risk yeah
no way there's no way you could
ethically justify that no
yeah um we've been going almost three
hours so we have to go
there but i can't let you go i do want
to ask you um before i let you go
i know that you work with google and i'm
interested
in i used to work with google you used
to okay um
in in that capacity were you able to um
help them implement certain policies
like what what kind of transpired there
in terms of the work culture that was
going on
and the impact that you know your work
had on that
culture yeah so i was actually working
with um
a a a part of google
that was called verily which is sort of
that was the
google health arm um and so it wasn't
focused on so it wasn't really focused
on going into there and changing the
culture it was more about sort of
you know developing uh either
technologies or it was also
you know um they have some remarkable
studies in there they're public about
this so
there's some aspects that i can share
where they're looking at
how um things such as sleep impact
different aspects of human health
so that they're doing wonderful things
in trying to augment
things like diabetes risk cardiovascular
risk
um and so you know i think what they
realized is that when you're looking at
all of these disease states based on
everything that we've spoken about for
the past
uh three minutes which now is now three
hours uh talking about time dilation
um right we're having our own inception
yeah we are really um
and so we are dreaming i i'm gonna wake
up and the alarm goes off and i thought
oh i'm so sad i thought i was on the
ritual podcast
it's tomorrow yeah and so
knowing how critical sleep is you know
the foundation they realized that there
had to be some
you know component of sleep appreciation
within that framework of everything that
they were trying to do so
i was so fortunate enough to be able to
do that um
and i no longer work with them i've got
a couple of uh
startups that i'm now advising and
working for and
um and so that was really i think the
the push there
which was that sleep is the tide that
rises
all the other health boats and i
remember when i was
sort of speaking early with them you
know i always almost had this analogy
where
if you think about a music studio and
those recording decks with all of those
dials
um and you can sort of mix and just sort
of tweak them what we're doing in health
is trying to sort of go to individual
dials we're trying to manipulate
cardiovascular health or
change immune health or change you know
metabolic and diabetes health
but there's that one sort of dial all
the way over to the left that if you
move it all the way up
all of the other dials go up as well the
master dial
that's sleep sleep is the archimedes
lever
um you know if i think if i were to have
something a single sentence i would say
that sleep is the single most effective
thing that we can do
each day to reset the health of our
brain and our body
mm-hmm that would be a beautiful place
to end this
but i just realized there's an important
thing we also didn't talk about that i
would like you to touch on quickly yeah
of course which is the
the you we you talked to the at the
outset
about what happens when you get a flu
shot and you're sleep deprived
we're still in the midst of this
pandemic we're slowly emerging out of it
but can you
talk a little bit about what you've
learned about um
sleep covid um immunity
and how people should be kind of
thinking about
how their relationship with with the
virus
yeah so let me uh i'll speak about sleep
and immunity
sort of more generally and then come on
to sleep and code because
sleep has changed in at least four
different ways because of covid
quantity quality timing and dreaming
um so i'll try to mentally put those
stickies up on my cerebral wall
so i come back to them but in terms of
sleep and immunity there is a
very intimate association between your
sleep health and your immune health
firstly what we know is that individuals
who report sleeping less than seven
hours a night are almost
three times more likely to become
infected by the rhinovirus
which is the common cold second we know
from a prospective study in
i think it was well over thirty thousand
women women sleeping five hours or less
a night
are um more than sixty percent more
likely to develop pneumonia across a
five-year period
which of course is a critical part of
the covid mortality equation
we've also mentioned that statistic
about if you're not getting
sleep in in the week before you get your
flu shot you can't produce the normal
antibody response
do we know that that's the case for
covid yet no we don't but we're looking
at that
we also know it's the case for hepatitis
a hepatitis b vaccination two
so i think there's a an interesting case
to be made that it could make a
difference
um we also know that um
just as we mentioned before just one
night of short sleep you know just four
hours will drop those critical
anti-cancer fighting cells natural kill
cells
by 70 if that's
true then why what is sleep doing
for our emotional health and sleep
provides us with that
sort of sorry for not emotional health
for our immune health
it provides us two different benefits
firstly it's during sleep and
particularly during deep sleep
where the body will be stimulated to
produce many more of those critical
immune factors
even better the sleep will actually
increase the sensitivity and the
receptivity of your body
to those increased immune factors
so you wake up the next morning as
a more robust immune individual sleep
will
restock the weaponry in your immune
arsenal so
on that basis i think sleep has become
very relevant
in this pandemic how is sleep changed
right now well
as i mentioned firstly the studies show
on average which may be surprising to
some people
sleep duration has actually increased
somewhere between about
20 to 30 minutes if you look at the
handful of studies
not commuting to get kids to school so
um so that's the first issue now if you
look at that data a bit more closely
it's it's not that clear it's not that
clean cut or straightforward
there is a cloud of data of people for
whom
sleep has actually become worse you know
people have lost their jobs
people don't know if they will still
have their jobs people are just
you know very anxious about the pandemic
all of those things
will you know decimate sleep of course
so sleep quantity has
um changed sleep quality has changed
also
but we also know that sleep timing has
changed
how are you getting that extra sleep
well people are going to bed
a little bit later but they're waking up
significantly later
and i think this comes back to our
discussion of chronotype
now covid because we don't have to
commute and wake up or do early morning
meetings or get the kids to school
many people have been able to sleep back
in synchrony where then with their
natural chronotype you know
it's revenge of the night owls
in that way and then the final component
is that people
and i think we we don't yet have enough
data
but there's too many people saying this
that they were dreaming more
and dreaming more about covid why would
this be i think there are two logical
explanations
the first just as we mentioned before
the later that you sleep
into the morning the more you go into
that rem sleep rich phase
so you're just giving yourself
probabilistic chance statistically of
having more dreams
but i don't think that's the entire
explanation
we also have spoken about this idea that
rem sleep provides this
form of emotional first aid it's
overnight therapy
um in fact there's an american
entrepreneur e joseph kosman who had
this lovely line he said that the best
bridge between despair
and hope is a good night of sleep
and i think when we're going through
these you know difficult emotionally
upheaval time of a pandemic
no wonder the brain is trying to
self-medicate
it you know this emotional situation
with the thing that it knows
provides a nocturnal soothing bomb which
is this thing called rem sleep and
dreaming
i think that's probably another
explanation as to why we're not just
dreaming more
but we're dreaming about the pandemic
itself
trying to make sense of it trying to
process it trying to figure out a way to
kind of have a healthier relationship
with it that's right yeah it just
you know sleep divorces some of the
emotion from the memory
so that you come back the next day and
you feel better about those
emotional experiences because sleep has
essentially
stripped the bitter emotional rind from
the informational
orange so it's not as though you wake up
the next day and you don't remember that
emotional experience you do
but it it's no longer as emotional
itself
and so it's not time that heals all
wounds
it's time during sleep and specifically
dream sleep
that provides emotional convalescence
it would be on on the immunity subject
it would be interesting to do
an evaluation of
people that got coveted how severe their
case of covid was and
and track that onto their sleep habits
and patterns
i think that's a people are doing that
um and we're looking at that we're also
looking at
um when you get vaccinated what are the
consequences some people are describing
disruptions to their sleep
usually what will happen is that you
will have some degree of fever
when you go into fever that increases
your core body temperature when your
body temperature increases
you're not going to get good sleep um
there are some devices
that are now and um i were the aura ring
sleep drinking device and full sort of
dis disclosure i i advise the company so
take anything i say with a grain of salt
but
i was wearing the device for two i've
worn just about every
sleep tracking device and it was just
the one that for me you know was a
sticky device and
and i liked it um so i was wearing it
for two years before
i i decided to join the company but
they have a fascinating model what
they've been able to find because the
aura ring
unlike many of these other um sort of
devices it tracks temperature
right and what they were finding is that
in some people who
then went on a day later or two days
later
to find out that they tested positive
for covid there was this spike
in their relative temperature yeah and
so you know we're now starting to
explore this idea that it could be
a useful diagnostic tool
exactly i mean i've got the woop on and
they manage that not through temperature
but through metabolic rate
yeah yeah and they have some interesting
science on that as well so it's it's
cool how these wearables
are sort of developing and how the
technology is evolving but
we're only beginning to understand like
the the significance that they can play
yeah exactly you know i think i
mentioned this invasion of technology
into the bedroom and it has been a
deleterious force
but perhaps unlike some other sort of
sleep scientists
i'm not puritanical about technology you
know that genie is out the bottle
and it's not going back in anytime soon
so if you want to rail against it you'll
lose
but what we're now seeing is this
beautiful sort of cycle
where technology is starting to solve
some of the problems of technology and
it's like that light in the matrix
you know programs hacking programs and
it's
technology starting to hack the ills of
technology
so i do think that um wearable
technology um has a place to
a part to play in a place in our
subsequent future health this idea of
personalized medicine and for me i'm
interested in personalized sleep
medicine that's why i'm trying to sort
of develop some of these companies
um but i also think we need to be a
little bit careful there's now something
called
orthosomnia which is
a sleep disorder caused by obsessive
sleep tracking where you become so
anxious and so
now it seems to be maybe 10 to 15
of the people who are using these suffer
from or by the way orthosomnia comes
from you've
um although means straighten in medicine
you know you've heard of orthopedics
orthodontics straightened teeth
straightened bones
here it's about people getting too
concerned about getting their sleep
straight
yeah orthosomnia yeah yeah i mean 100 i
mean i think they're they're just tools
it's about your relationship too that's
right but if you become obsessive about
them they work across purposes with
their intent like
yeah i know there are certain days where
i'm not sure i really want to look at
whatever the whoop score is because
i got stuff to do and if it says like
i'm not ready for it that's going to
screw me up like
i just would rather i'll check it later
i use them
as i think they're for me my
relationship to them is more in the
macro like i can look at trends over
time
exactly or or i play a game where i wake
up in the morning and i'll think
i'm pretty sure here's where i'm at and
then i'll check it and that that helps
me calibrate my intuition around these
things and the more intuitive you are
about them
the less reliant upon them i think you
become but you have to hold them a
little bit lightly
i love that i think that's it's such a
beautiful way of thinking about it you
know often what i will say to people
when the
they say look i had this really bad
night of sleep and i i don't want to
look at my
ring firstly everyone has a bad night of
sleep don't worry about it it's not the
end of the world
the second thing when it comes to
trackers of any kind and particularly
with sleep
follow weekly or monthly trend lines
don't follow nightly headlines don't
worry about those things
and i think the reason i i believe sleep
tracking is perhaps a little bit
different than other
aspects of health wearable tracking when
i go to the gym
i kind of know if i got a good workout
in or if i didn't
and when i've been eating throughout the
day i know if i've been eating clean
and in a healthy way or if i haven't you
know you don't want to score on that
and i i think i probably will know it
and some days i'm ashamed of it
but what's interesting about sleep is
that for the most part it's a
non-conscious process
and so if i were to ask you you know
rich last night how did you sleep you
can tell me
but if i said to you rich how did you
sleep last tuesday
by yourself you probably don't know
right but that's where i think the power
of some of this technology it can
identify
trends and patterns and if we can start
to measure those and then
intervene to give people useful tips as
to what they should do in a personalized
manner
because everyone is sleeping poorly for
different reasons
that's really where we unleash the power
of these things
matt walker we got to end this thing so
great talking to you will you come back
and talk to me again sometime
if you would have me and if your
listeners uh don't lose the will to live
because of my uh
inane voice i don't know i would be
delighted believable to come back
you are a gift my friend uh the work
that you're doing i think is super
important it's a privilege and an honor
to help amplify it a little bit
so i really appreciate what you do um
it's a great act of service to humankind
so thank you for that and thank you for
spending the afternoon with me
i say exactly the same thing back to you
based on what you're doing
um your honesty and your vulnerability
of story has impacted people i know
and what you're doing with this movement
around this podcast and empowering
people with
mind-body um guidance and information
i think is fundamentally critical so you
are a gift um
and now i i anoint you as a sleep
ambassador as well so
rich thank you you know i'll have a
terrible night of sleep
tonight just call me put me on speed
dial i'll
i'll help you i'm going to call you
every night am i doing this right
yeah don't worry i will be right there
for you um thank you so much for having
me thank you
um you can find and learn about matthew
at thesleepdiplomat.com yes diplomat
um or if you want you can read the book
which is called why we sleep
um you don't have to um read the book
you just have to buy it is what the
publishers tell me
no you got to read it but um no just buy
a used copy i don't i'm not
interested in a in monetary stuff but
if you're able or if you're interested
in learning more about sleep um the book
is a good way to do it good
well let's let's do this again sometime
i hope so all right thank you rich peace
[Music]
you